on some level wisdom is a matter of
making your mind your friend my friend
Sam Harris Sam Harris Sam Harris one of
the most influential pioneering thinkers
of our time the more you pay attention
to your own mind you see that it has
absolutely no shame wisdom is simply a
capacity to take your own advice
Sam Harris welcome to the show thank you
great to meet you finally what is life
like after Twitter
uh uh it is immensely improved to a
degree that I find
actually embarrassing in retrospect
because it's a it's proof that I was
needlessly degrading the quality of my
life
for um
most 12 years technically I think was
probably five years where it was
actually degrading the quality of my
life but it was
um
I mean retrospective was a psychological
experiment that we all got enrolled in
and no one you know read the consent
form much less signed it and it we it it
has
given for me if you're someone who has a
significant platform
and you're at all controversial
I think it gives you a sense of what the
world is which
um
is basically false and destructive to
your your feeling the feelings you have
for the rest of humanity I mean it was
it was it was kind of sort of
incrementally like a slow ratchet
um but never to be reversed
um
all often undetectable but still
nevertheless always in One Direction
changing me into a misanthrope I mean I
was just starting to perceive people who
I had never met and
um many who I had met as the worst most
grotesque versions of themselves and
it's not that it's totally inaccurate
it's not that you know I mean people
people tweet what you see them at their
worst moments or or their most bad faith
moments or their most cynical moments
um
but
it's like the evidence of that of those
moments becomes indelible and you lose
sight of the rest and I just was
noticing this mismatch of you know being
out in the world with people and people
are great and then checking into my life
online and recognizing that people are
horrible
and just bouncing back between these two
views and I just realized I really only
wanted one of them
it seems to me that a lot of people feel
that that when they step out into the
real world and the people who spend more
time in the real world they realize this
is kind of nice everyone seems pretty
balanced out here no one's that
antagonistic no one's backbiting or
Screaming or shouting or accusing me of
being a bigot or a racist or or whatever
and then for some reason you step onto
the internet with frictionless
communication and
all hell breaks loose yeah yeah and it's
not just anonymity anonymity is part of
it but it's also people you know who are
captured by their Echo chamber which
you're not seeing right like it's this
illusion that you're in inhabiting the
same space with the people you're you're
in conversation with but
in reality they're talking to their fans
you're talking to your fans your kind of
you have weaponized your fans against
their fans and and vice versa and
without even necessarily thinking in
those terms that's that those are the
the network dynamics of what's happening
and
um
I mean I just I just kept getting at one
point I recognized that
barring some
you know bad Health outcomes in among
friends and family over the years
objectively the worst things that had
happened to me in a decade were the
result of my engagement with Twitter
um and in many cases the only bad things
that had happened to me in a decade of
any significance at all was born of
Twitter I think he managed to torpedo a
family vacation in some beauty yeah yeah
that was Paradise by sending a a random
tweet and then putting your phone down
to come back to it and find out that
there was a wasteland yeah it was a yeah
yeah no it was it just it kept giving
giving me a sense it was a the time
course of interaction with it
gives you this I mean this is endless
opportunity to comment on stuff it's
like it's always ready for your hot take
in fact you're you're on there to give
your hot take and to see the hot takes
of others
um again this might not matter if your
hot take is here's another cute photo of
my cat and you just get nothing but love
back right I know this there are people
that have that experience
uh but
given that I was
violating the
the blasphemy tests of both the left and
the right more or less on a weekly basis
I mean I'm not aligned politically with
the left or the right
um
you know it was just paying on both
sides and I you know I and I had no
tribe like if you're if you're just on
the right you know or or some
segment of the right if you're you know
Ben Shapiro
um you have a tribe that is going to
just
incessantly defend you against the left
right and you and at a certain point you
just you learn to Discount the attacks
of the left because you don't care what
the left thinks about you you've priced
that in you know you're on the right
um
and so it is with the left if you're in
the middle and you're actually not even
an especially political person you don't
even you don't care about politics
politics are it's just an ugly necessity
that you continually have to touch but
it's just you view it as a an
opportunity cost getting in the way of
the things you actually care about
and you're not tribal and you're not
reflexively aligned with with you know
the the bullet points on on one side of
the aisle or the other
you have you have offended everyone on
both sides at some point getting
ideologically spit roasted here yeah and
you're not and you don't have you don't
have the people who will defend you
blindly
even within your own audience which is
which is fine I mean I'm I'm very happy
to have the audience I have and I I like
having an audience that
really cares about the integrity and
honesty of the very last thing I said
and if the last thing I said didn't make
sense they're going to I'm going to hear
about it but
social media is just the wrong platform
for that kind of conversation do you
ever think about what civilization would
be like without social media you know
some of the smartest minds of our time
have had the
hours captured arguing over whether men
or men or women or women or not or yeah
about this particular topic or that
particular topic do you think about how
far it's satisfied is it in that
negative positive overall do you think
well I think it's a net negative I think
it's a massive opportunity cost for
almost everybody
um I just think where you know you look
at what you're doing and not doing based
on your engagement with these platforms
I mean you're not tending to read good
long books anymore either at minimum
even if it's your job to read those
books it's become harder to do that and
I wasn't certainly noticing that for
myself
um
it's uh
we're just it has served to fragment our
attention and our lives in ways that I
just can't be good you know even if
again even if your diet of information
is almost entirely positive there's this
fragmentation effect you know it's like
you just I mean I notice people
certainly I notice young people now
who are
who appear almost neurologically
incapable of watching a great movie from
beginning to end without interruption
you know what's cool if you Google the
number of cuts in the first fast and
furious movie compared to the number of
cuts in the 10th Fast and Furious movie
yeah Pace right yeah it's got to be sped
up yeah so I mean I'm noticing this with
my daughters it's like to get them to
watch a movie
yeah it's not it's not that it's
impossible but I just noticed that
they're they're tuned to a different
Cadence and
um and they're not even on I mean
they're you know they're not on social
media in the normal way I mean they
don't have social media accounts they're
just but the the YouTube application of
everything has gotten in and um yeah I
think it's worth resisting you know it's
not that we don't have to use these
tools in some way but
I think it is worth realizing
that
even Beyond Time your attention is what
you have your true wealth is the quality
of your attention and we have we've now
interfaced with Machinery that has
systematically degraded our ability to
pay attention
David perrell has this idea called the
never-ending now and if you look at the
content that you've consumed maybe not
you after your exit but most people
almost all of the content that you have
consumed today has been made in the last
24 hours right it's never ending now
terrifying it's the opposite of Lindy
it's the opposite of the Lindy effect
right it is so
thoughtless
and it's yet it's captivating right I
mean it's just the sugar high of you
know everything so
um yeah so I'm you know I've I'm more
focused on good books now than I was
before I deleted my Twitter account
which is which is good have you
reflected much on Tucker Carlson's move
to Twitter from Fox News is this the
beginning of some Legacy to Alternative
media Breakwater event or is it just a
nothingy to you
well I mean I think Tucker Carlson
himself is um
worth considering I mean we know you
know he's he's someone who has shield
for Trump you know rather avidly for
years and yet we now have his behind the
scenes commentary on the Trump
phenomenon describing him as a demonic
force and somebody who he hates with a
passion that's what Chuck has said about
Trump yeah this can't this came out of
his texts got leaked from the the
Dominion lawsuit against Fox okay right
so we know like like the mismatch
between who he is pretending to be for
his on his audience and who he is behind
closed doors is something that I think
should trouble his audience but it
apparently doesn't right and that's also
true of someone like Trump so in many
cases you have these characters who
to my eye are very low Integrity people
I mean they're not that you know you're
not getting an honest look at what they
really think even though they're
purporting to tell you what they think
you know every hour of the day or at
least every day for some hours
um
and you know if you Tucker is that sort
of person but I you know I think it
we're in a
we're on a political landscape now where
there's no impediment to his building an
enormous business on the basis of of
having left fox or having gotten fired
from Fox
um for reasons that which I guess are
still obscure
um
I mean he's very good at what he does
he's a very good demagogue and he's he's
very facile
um
I don't think there's an ethical core
there but there's a
a political one you know or it's
certainly not an opportunist uh one in
the political space and
there's a there's an immense appetite to
have someone
call on
the powers that be the so-called Elites
the institutions
again and again and again whether
they're right or wrong you know it's
just like it's it's a this is how it
sort of opens the door to
conspiracy thinking of every flavor
um it's not that these contrary intakes
are always wrong because they're not
right I mean that we have we're living
through a time where
many of our institutions have
lost trust for good reason right but
get what gets layered on top of that are
just you know lies and misinformation
and half truths and and
uh a crazy sort of
you know John Nash style connect the
dots with everything and you can you can
find and if you're just searching for
anomalies and you're not actually held
to any sort of coherent standard of of
having a basic Theory as to what's going
on you just can find the next anomaly
well then you'll find anomalies
everywhere and they don't have to add up
to anything except a kind of pornography
of Doubt right and that's that's what's
being spread by people like Tucker in my
view did you see Douglas Murray's debate
with Malcolm Gladwell mataibi
um
I think I heard uh most of it yeah yeah
and on that it was a discussion around
is the new alternative media is this
where we're getting the most truth from
the unencumbered the audience capture
incentives are there but also you are
liberated to not be
tamped down by whoever the bigwigs are
that have got some nefarious agenda but
then the other side is saying it's this
freewheeling wild west where people can
just make all manner of these sorts of
claims what did you make of uh of that
landscape
well I mean so I'm very biased for that
particular debate I love douglas douglas
is a friend and he's he's obviously
brilliant and just a joy to listen to
um
and I get a lot of his hate mail because
okay he's again he's he's somebody who's
happily on the right or right of Center
who doesn't have to worry about what the
left thinks about him but you know every
time I have him on the podcast I get
nothing but pain from half my audience
if there is anything that is worth the
pain of half of your audience is
bringing Douglas Marine yeah yeah no
he's fantastic but um he is adjacent to
many people who are not so fantastic
right this is this is the sort of
guilt by association problem that he has
um
navigated in a way which I you know I
don't know if it's successful I mean
it's he's I think sleeps soundly at
night given what he's done but the truth
is he has been he's shared stages with
people who I wouldn't want to be on
stage with and I don't think it was good
for him to be on a stage with the person
and half of the reason why I would get
hate mail about having Douglas on would
be because he shared the stage with
those people
um
and
yet it's he's completely correct in
recognizing how hopeless it is to do a
full moral inventory of everyone you
might be you know forced to shake hands
with and to decide in advance whether
it's worth shaking their hands or having
a conversation with them
um
so yeah I mean we're just it is the wild
west and you just have to do your best
and uh just be honest whenever you're in
front of the microphone it feels to me
like that guilt by association thing
seems to have slowed at least a little
bit PS Morgan put out a video recently
about uh we're at Peak woke yeah I
wouldn't agree I think uh I can't
remember whether it was it was Matt
taibi or somebody else in the summer of
2020 said that that was Peak walk uh the
most you know inflammatory over the top
any slight indiscretion is worth being
smashed in the face for right uh I
wouldn't agree that that's the case now
and it seems to me like there is at
least a little bit more reason beginning
to seep back in to that discourse I I
hope so I feel like
it seems to be the case for me except I
don't know if it's just a an optical
illusion because I'm no longer on
Twitter and I no longer care right like
so I just don't you know I used there's
certain kinds of attacks which a few
years ago I might have taken seriously
for 15 minutes and now they just are an
entire holiday in Hawaii yeah but now
they just bounce off or I don't even see
them right so
um and
that may be a good thing I mean
certainly
it's a nicer way of being in the world
but it could be
a version of of
something like digital leprosy right
where you're like you know the lepers
lose their digits because they don't
they don't sense pain anymore and they
you know you walk by a table and you
whack your fingers on it and you don't
notice that you're bleeding
um I think in the worst cases in the
developing World literally you know rats
can come non you while you're sleeping
and you don't feel that either
um so
it could be that I have a a digital
version of that which is just that I
just don't I'm not noticing how my
reputation is eroding in ways that I
actually would care about if I could
notice it but I can no longer sense it
because I'm in my own Silo
um
but the truth is I just don't care about
certain kinds of attacks anymore and so
yeah I have the perception you have that
the pendulum has swung back people are
rolling even people who would otherwise
have been taken in by
wokeness a few years ago
roll their eyes in private and
increasingly in public over certain
kinds of yeah you know ad hominem or bad
faith arguments or
um
but so back to this point with Douglas I
mean I just you know so my bias was a
you know his side carried that debate
you know spectacularly well
um
but
and the truth is I don't know Malco I've
been on his podcast but I so I've spoken
to him but I don't know Malcolm Malcolm
has a
it's not the first time he's done this
in debate he has he has a habit and
debate of being
ad hominem in a way that is if it's ever
persuasive it's not persuasive when he's
doing it and so it just you sort of lose
uh just uh just by default whatever the
actual topic uh you know under
discussion
do you remember the talk that you gave
on death and the present moment I think
it was the atheists Australian new
atheist Society something like that it
was a big uh it was called the global
atheist convention but you're a global
atheist Alliance but
um I think at the at that point maybe
still it was like the biggest atheist
convention ever
um so I went to a few of those but that
was that was one how should it inform
the way that we live our lives do you
think given that we know that they're
going to end sooner or later
well I really think that is the
whether you think about it or not that
is the ever-present
subtext to almost everything you you
care about should care about fail to you
know when you when your priorities are
not straight you know you've
when you when you have regrets it's in
the light it's against this
the uh
the incessant taking of the clock
that that all of that makes sense and
the imperative of
of
um
the incremental loss of this
non-renewable resource you know it's
like it's the one thing you don't get
back and as I said I think even more
than time attention is is the the real
cash value of time but
um because we know that you can
Safeguard your time and squander it
right so it's like it's it's and you and
we know you can find
real Joy surprising joy and Equanimity
and and even Transcendent experience
in the midst of
experiences that you wouldn't otherwise
think were optimal right you can have
you could you could be in a shitty
situation where nothing has really gone
the way you expected
and still be radiantly happy right it
really is a matter of what you're doing
with your attention and the kind of mind
you have
um
but
the fact is that everything is changing
at every moment and we're not there's no
real stability right there's no
final stage of control over experience
every every goal you attain becomes a
memory the moment you attain it right
and then you then you're just left to
think about it right and then the
question is what are you going to do
next and we have this Perpetual
challenge
of figuring out what to do next I mean
what you know morally intellectually as
a matter of just trying to to safeguard
our own sense of well-being
and you're never you never arrive and
it's because of this the the the nature
of impermanence that you never do I mean
everything is in fact a mirage if you
think that your satisfaction is going to
be a matter of
finally put in
all of the the most important features
of your life in the correct place right
like you finally have the job you want
the relationship you want the house you
want you know you're in your your fit
you're healthy you're like you you just
you've you've executed on the perfect
to-do list and you finally arrived well
at a minimum
you're going to notice that all of that
has to be maintained at Great energy
right like it take entropy is such that
you know you can't stay fit you can't
stay healthy you can't stay Rich you
can't you can't your relationship's not
going to maintain itself and what's more
most people's minds are out of control
anyway right and and they're not
satisfied anyway even having everything
they the moment you have everything your
your sense of what you want I mean you
just move the goal posts or they got
moved for you by some hand that you
could never see and so like you take all
of this for granted and now you want
other things and you want them just as
much as you wanted the last things
uh so
there is this there's something about
the passage of time
that as you pay attention to it and as
you get older this this is
relevant but I mean some people get
managed to get quite old without getting
especially wise but other things can
happen even when you're young you can
you know you can lose people close to
you or you can you can do suffer some
profound career setback or something can
happen where you recognize okay this is
there's a
there's a false premise here there's
many bright shiny objects I've been
focused on with it because they've been
you know captivating for
cultural and psychological reasons that
I never inspected and never really
agreed to but that you know that's just
where my attention went and
there's this deeper principle which is
the effort to become happy
never fully fulfills itself right
because it's the becoming part contains
its own dissatisfaction right like at a
certain level you have to figure out how
you can be happy with whatever is
already the case like to to want what
you already have
and then from that place move into the
next moment
looking to do creative beautiful fun
things but your your happiness is not
contingent upon those things working out
in any particular way right you you
realize that you're just at some level
you have to be process oriented rather
than goal oriented because
ultimately there is only the process
right and your ha and the goals and the
goals are so the achievement of the
goals is such a punctate experience it's
so brief it's just a it's an idea before
it happens it's an idea the moment it
happens it's some burst of sensory
experience and then it's an idea again
it's a memory and you're talking about
you're talking about the thing you did
yesterday
um
that's not good enough that could never
have been good enough for a truly
satisfied Life we'll get back to talking
to Sam in one minute but first I need to
tell you about a sponsor betterhelp
there might be something interfering
with your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your goals it is
unbelievably helpful to have someone
professionally trained who can help you
get through whatever you're facing the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
at any time and send a message to your
therapist they'll give you timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you don't even have to leave the
house it is a quicker cheaper and more
convenient way to start doing therapy
and you do not know just how good the
texture of your own mind could be if you
started working with someone
professionally trained who can help you
get through whatever you're facing you
can switch therapists for free if it
doesn't work out for any reason and
there is no additional charge head to
betterhelp.com Modern wisdom to get 10
off your first month of therapy that's
betterhelp.com slash modern wisdom
someone that you might not have been
expecting to give you mindful wisdom
that you might agree with Andrew Tate
has a quote where he says uh having
things isn't fun getting things is fun
and I think that what he's referring to
there is the the hedonic treadmill that
we're talking about the fact that right
it's in the anticipation of an event
that we think it's going to happen as a
club promoter for forever and we would
be creating anticipation for this next
new DJ this next new whatever that would
happen but the protracted nature of the
build up was what people looked forward
to yeah I look forward to the advance of
it when the event happened in fact they
did a study where they got people to
track they pinged their phones and got
them to track how their happiness was
throughout the entirety of a night out
and the most fun part of a night out is
getting ready with your friends before
you head out of the door yeah I mean
neuroanatomically the reason why that is
the case because this is our
dopaminergic system gets driven not by
Pleasure itself but by the expectation
of pleasure that the things we're about
to get based it's the the center of the
bullseye is
the S the the pleasant surprise like
this is about to get better than I was
expecting right that that's the thing
that that is truly reinforcing yeah I
fear I might have uh made an error by
saying that I have a guest coming on
that I was very excited about and now if
if someone isn't sufficiently excited
about you then that dopaminergic system
is going to fall through there yeah yeah
there's one disappointment after another
but like Andrew takes a perfect example
of somebody who again he's not
um he's radioactive for obvious reasons
I haven't met him I haven't done an
especially Deep dive on what he's guilty
of or you know I mean he's obviously
he's
he's got issues but um
I just feel like we're at a moment now
where
there is such a a thirst for wisdom
that you know it's okay it can come from
so many different places and those
places can be more or less contaminated
with Concepts that are more or less
toxic more or less divisive more or less
confusing and
yeah I mean I've what you know
I've watched enough of his stuff to see
why young men are getting addicted to
his content and thinking that he's their
their life Guru uh and I've also watched
enough to think that it's not um
it's not ideal that he's the voice of a
generation right like we need a a um
a more compassionate less
self-invatuated
uh standard for manliness and and
success that then whether he's he's
putting out if I was to I've got Jordan
uh coming on the show again at some
point later this year and it's something
that I think I'll speak to him about
that he's on to big things with this Arc
which is kind of his competitor I think
to the wef that he's doing later this
year yeah I haven't I haven't followed
that yeah
um but I do think that Jordan's relative
abandonment of the conversation directly
to young men uh to move on to other
things whether it be
climate change or the trans issue or
pick your poison about whatever he's got
interested in recently I think that that
has left a vacuum and you can't expect
young you can't expect anybody to go
through life without insights coming
from somewhere and whether that Insight
is for young men or young women or old
men or old women whether it's Andrew
Tate or you know Whoopi Goldberg or
whoever happens to have the hot take of
the week and and transufficiently highly
on Twitter uh
people are going to look for someone
they're going to look for answers and in
a world where we are
chronically mismatched our evolved
psychology and the world that we find
ourselves in has never really been
further apart
people are going to find answers and and
sometimes
fluency is a really brilliant proxy for
truthfulness or insight and if you can
say things with a sufficiently
well-rounded compelling delivery
regardless of who you are yeah whether
it be Whoopi Goldberg or anybody else
people will say that sounds that sounds
true sounds fluent not sure if it's true
yeah except the thing that surprises me
is that
it should be more obvious than it is to
more people
that someone's an right it's
like that like it doesn't matter how
fluent you are you are you're only just
declaring your assholery in in more
concise form right
um and
so it's kind of a trumpian moment like
Trump is obviously an he's
obviously a a selfish person but nobody
none of his fans care right he's like
he's not a compassionate person he's he
can't even pretend to care about people
really right he's but his
his shamelessness around his selfishness
has become a kind of superpower for a
certain audience because he's he's
conveying the message
I will never I will never judge you
because I'm incapable of judging myself
right like I'm not I I'm not holding
myself to any kind of standard apart
from the gratification of my own desires
so you know I'm I'm in some sense I have
a real Integrity because I know I'm
selfish all those people who are
pretending not to be selfish or
pretending to be ethical and
compassionate to care about you know the
sub-Saharan Africa and the you know the
education and developing countries I
mean someone like Bill Gates right you
know Bill Gates is somebody who can't
get laid and he's just going to
microchip you with the next vaccine
right like that that's this is going to
be a great uh quote to export from this
podcast
um
uh you're welcome Twitter
that so that's the that's the center of
narrative and ethical gravity for these
guys right I don't include Jordan there
but like Andrew Tate Trump there's like
a I've got a Bugatti and you
know you want one and I've got no
apologies right I've got no to
give uh I know you want to be like me
you know and if you don't if you're not
good enough to be like me I'll sleep
with your girlfriend right like that's
that's the that's not an ethically wise
person on any level even if he
can even if he can string together a few
sentences that seem actionable and
useful to get you to clean your room and
get in shape and and meet a girl right
um we should be asking more of our
elders than that right and and so and so
where I part ways with Jordan again I do
not put Jordan
um in the same category but he is
he has a very different view of the
the the kind of the status of objective
empirical truth in relation to the
stories we tell about
uh ourselves and our place in the world
and
um what makes life worth living what
what a lot what will allow for a society
to really cohere around shared values
and he thinks that there's a a layer of
storytelling and you know what I would
what I would call myth and fiction
really in a way that is
kind of somewhat derogatory right it's
not to say that I'm I don't see the
power in it but it's just I what I want
to do is be able to distinguish between
the
a layer of wishful thinking
and a layer of delusion and a layer of
uh ancient confusion that is still has
good standing among millions of people
and probably some symbolic truth or
figurative truth in there too and and a
kind of harmless harmless uses of the
imagination that it could be a nobling
and fun and empowering right
um and
kind of core truths that don't require a
story to be a Noble in there did you see
that Jordan got into it with Richard
Dawkins on well you wouldn't have done
you're you're off Twitter so I will no
I'll uh be the Weathervane to update you
on whatever's happening in Twitter's
conditions at the moment uh
Richard's a clip of Richard one
semi-viral of him criticizing the Old
Testament God right and then I think
Jordan basically called him out Anytime
Anyplace anywhere it wasn't far off that
I think that the actual tweet was about
saying that it was uh I think damaging
science and and and doing a disservice
to
maybe Dawkins himself and and other
stuff yeah well so I mean that's
I mean I agree with Richard yeah with
respect to the
what I think of the the Old Testament
God and the the moral instruction we can
or can't take from him I mean I just
think that's I just don't think that the
the Bible is the wisest book we have
even though there are there are Pearls
of real wisdom there which I I
understand that people love
um
it's a book it was clearly written by
human beings right so like the
fundamental the the breach point is not
is is Upstream of many of the things
people might want to debate there's just
this basic claim we've got millions upon
millions of books
were they all written by people or not
right and the moment you admit that they
were all written by people okay we're
having a very different conversation
about the status of religion certainly
the religion of of any of the religions
of Abraham right I mean these are these
are claimed at bottom Judaism
Christianity and Islam are claims about
the divine origin of of a specific book
or certain texts
um and some of these texts were
canonical for centuries and then got
thrown out you know within within
Christianity and then some got added
later
um so the the process of cobbling
together these these scriptures was all
too human we know way too much about it
if you if we knew more about it it would
look much more like Joseph Smith and the
Book of Mormon and the and it would look
like a you know the South Park episode
that Mormonism in fact looks like right
and you drag it further into the present
and it looks like Scientology right and
then you're like you're just staring at
L Ron Hubbard's driver's license and it
says okay this goofy guy with bad teeth
sold all these people honest on a story
about the stars that was just obviously
and should it should have been
obvious to them now again that's not to
say that there isn't real wisdom in in
all of these streams of information even
Scientology but
you just
the basic claim and I think Richard
would agree with this is that you don't
have to believe anything on insufficient
evidence to extract
all the wisdom that is to be found in
the world's literature and in the
conversations conversations with people
in the present and conversations with
the dead by reading their their books in
other news this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep eight sleeps pod
cover is keeping me alive in the middle
of summer in Austin Texas at the moment
good sleep is the Ultimate Game Changer
and being too hot or too cold is a
guaranteed way to ruin your night's
sleep the Pod cover from eight sleep
will actively cool and heat each
different side of the bed based on yours
and your partner's sleep stages it is a
complete Game Changer and if you're
waking up in the morning feeling groggy
and not sufficiently rested it is quite
likely that temperature is the culprit
and all of this is fixed with the Pod
cover from eight sleep it slips over the
top of your existing mattress just like
a mattress topper but gives you all of
the biometric scanning it'll tell you
how long you're asleep for your resting
heart rate your HIV everything literally
from a mattress topper head to
atesleep.com Modern wisdom or follow the
link in the show notes below for 150 off
plus they share ship internationally
that's e i g h t sleep.com slash modern
wisdom the first time that I think I
heard of Jordan was that first
conversation that you guys had it was a
a podcast maybe in a bar even a hotel
reception or something and it was a
jinking of glasses oh no that would have
been probably Dan it uh Dan and I had a
debate in a bar but uh Jordan and I had
a debate on my podcast right I'd heard
this uh heard this conversation and I
remember thinking who's this Canadian
having a part of Sam Harris yeah uh
at the time and then later on went on to
to Really sort of fall in love with
Jordan's work as well I think there's an
awful lot of people who want to see that
public relationship between you and him
rekindled uh well it hasn't I mean to my
eye it is not uh
been broken I mean I like Jordan I mean
I think this is just this is what I
imagined because I have not had any
dialogue with him in in a couple years
but
um
I mean Jordan and I disagree
fundamentally about religion I think and
we've debated that you know Ad nauseam
and we've probably got like 12 hours uh
you know on the mic in various venues
debating that um and that was fun and
I'm always happy to talk to him
um and I think he while we disagree I
think he has really helped millions of
people I mean I think he's there's no
question I've I I know what it's like to
be with him at an event and to hear from
the people who who are you know hear
from his fans and my fans side by side
sitting at a table for an hour after an
event where we you know had a debate in
front of 8 000 people
um
and there's a slightly different flavor
to the people whose lives we've changed
right he's he's intersected with a with
a different group of people at a
different point in their lives than I
have for the most how would you
categorize that difference
well I mean to significant degrees
people moving in two opposite direction
I mean like they're they're the people
who
were stuck with a religious worldview
stuck I mean literally in many cases
traumatized by a fear of hell that had
been inculcated into them by their
religious parents but
were enamored enough of Enlightenment
values and secular rationality and
science so as to have the
this the spell break to some significant
degree and they needed some language to
to help kind of Midwife their delivery
into a into the clear light of of reason
right and they also needed so and this
is where Richard and I have kind of have
had different jobs I mean Richard is
just
critiquing religion and counterposing it
with
all that's wonderful about science right
and so for him the the spiritual
attitude that is on offer when you once
you leave religion behind and you know
you know close the church doors behind
you is
awe at the beauty of Nature and just
amazement at you know everything we are
learning and may yet learn about the way
the world works and the way the mind
works and
um I mean we are
nothing to use Newton's image I mean
it's like we are children on a seashore
playing with shells and the vast ocean
of of ignorance and potential knowledge
it just awaits our our inspection
um
for me that's not good enough right what
I mean by spirituality
has in fact nothing to do with the
amazement that you feel when you look up
at the Milky Way right it's like that
that's that's great but that's just not
that's just not the
the real opportunity on offer and that's
not what's going to prepare us to die
you know and that's not what's going to
really console you at four in the
morning when you wake up feeling bad
about your life and not sure how you can
be happy in this world right
um
so I'm much more so I I'm convinced that
at the core of every religion there was
there there were real transformative and
and Transcendent human experiences that
are attested to by the literature and
traditions that have grown up around
that religion so there really was you
know presumably there really was a
person you know in history by the name
of Jesus who had this effect on the
people around him and said you know
something like what he has purported to
have said in the Bible
and I can I can understand all of that
as
a a absolutely predictable result of
certain ways of of paying attention that
are available to every human being now
you know then now then and now
um which allow you to recognize that
that this ego you take yourself to be is
an illusion and it allows you to
recognize that unconditional love is
actually a possibility right like you
can it's possible to
just feel
Shattered by your love for all sentient
beings and to just to bask in the
profundity of that way of being and
that's on the menu and whether you have
to just whether you have to go into a
cave and meditate for a month to find
that or you take MDMA or you have there
are ways to perturb your nervous system
such that
the testimony of Someone Like Jesus or
Buddha is not
is obviously not a fraud it's obviously
not a confession of Psychopathology it's
obviously not a delusion about
uh you know belief-based delusion about
what happens after death or about
invisible parts of the universe and
being populated by Angels or deities you
don't have to believe in anything
unempirical in order to experience that
range of of positive experience you just
have to learn to use your attention in
the right ways and and if you can't do
that you know there are you know
psychedelics offer a
an imperfect method
yeah I mean it's definitely reliable
it's a reliable glimpse of something
that is different enough
uh assuming you have a positive
experience I mean you can have a
different enough negative experience
that will convince you of something else
but if you have a different enough
extraordinarily positive experience
you'll be convinced that okay what
whatever
the possibilities of sustaining that may
or may not be
it is just clear that this experience is
possible because I just had it right I
just had it for four hours and
I can no longer imagine that human
consciousness is is in principle
confined to
kind of the mediocre bandwidth I tend to
experience when I'm just checking my
email and then checking Twitter and then
worrying about my future all right I
actually I actually don't think I I
actually closed the loop on what um
I wanted to say about Jordan there
though so
Jordan
Jordan and I differ in
he wants to support a much more
traditional picture of the utility and
even necessity of religious thinking and
religious identity and and that way of
giving meaning to one's life through
traditional stories and stories which I
think
foreign
a literal belief in can't be justified
based on what we have come to understand
about science and
um
I just think that
the burden is on us at this point in
history to find a truly non-sectarian
way of telling ourselves a story about
what we value and what is possible right
and and so and we do that in other areas
of Our Lives I mean science is one very
clear place we do that uh where there's
just there is no to say that you know
there's American Science versus Chinese
science and it's just that's just not
science like science is at a layer more
fundamental than those cultural
differences
um
and so it has to be with a with
something like ethics and spirituality
you can't talk in the end you can't you
shouldn't be able to talk about
Christian ethics or Christian spiritual
insight and Jordan's not convinced of
that or he's apparently not convinced of
that and so you know that that's what we
still disagree about but I think the
final I think the thing the thing I
wanted to say was that
so you you will seem to allude to some
sort of breach between us which I
certainly don't feel and have an
experience I can only imagine though
that in his world given given what was
happening to me on Twitter when I left
he perceives me as somebody who has just
um
gone off the rails in some way right
because like he he in his world and this
is this is what
was so amazing to see
um when I was looking at Twitter when I
when I made this to if anyone doesn't
know what I'm talking about there was
this whole Hunter Biden laptop situation
where I commented on the hunter Biden
laptop thing uh on a podcast
a clip from that podcast got exported to
you know apparently every
planet in the solar system and
um it had an enormous effect right of
center right so so right of Center I had
just destroyed my career I'm a little
I'm hearing from people like
oh my God are you okay right and in my
world and in every channel I care about
literally nothing had happened right and
so but in but Jordan lives in the world
where I just kind of torched everything
so I can only imagine that he has some
view of my I mean he the truth is I
would expect him to be
genuinely confused about what I believe
about things like free speech or you
know any of the relevant variables there
unless he happens to listen to my
podcast which you know I don't know
whether or not he does I think the uh
potential breach that I was talking
about was more just that there is a
hunger for you and him to speak I think
that you've both been formative to a lot
of people's intellectual Journeys in one
form or another and uh I I think people
are hoping that there is uh yet more
juice to squeeze from your conjoined
lemons and however way yeah that happens
well I'm always happy to talk to him I
think you know I think the thing that
got into my head is someone sent me a
clip from
Joe Rogan's podcast where he and Joe
were talking about me and
Jordan seemed to be talking about me as
like a cautionary tale like look what
can happen to somebody and and Joe said
something like oh I still have hope for
Sam and there in my view they are in
this contrarian Echo chamber right where
you know mRNA vaccines are terrifying
covid was no big deal January 6 was
maybe a non-event right
um the libtards are trying to ruin
everything and there's a whole picture
of sort of audience capture and and
information skewing there which I
understand I mean that's sort of how
like if I look to my left I can see all
that uh but if you're only there
there's just a lot of half truths you
know kind of ricocheting around that
Echo chamber which um
yeah it means I'm happy to talk to both
those guys but it's just they're not
in the in
in the lane I'm in and trying to
maintain You know despite the Crosswinds
trying to maintain a straight course in
there's that's only half the story right
so it's um and I just think people are
genuinely confused now because
two things are true
we have lost trust in the the normal
channels of information and in normal
institutions postcode you know during
coven and post covet
um for obvious reasons but we
desperately need institutions and a
media that we can trust right and we're
not going to navigate This Moment by
just proliferating podcasts and
newsletters right it's just not good
enough much as we might try yeah so it's
and so that's the that's a seeming
Paradox because yes you can point to the
moments where our institutions have
become untrustworthy
but you know RFK Jr is not the Messiah
we need at this moment why do you think
he's so hot at the moment what is it
about RFK well it's exactly he's he is
speaking very directly to this
um
contrarian Echo chamber you know
contrarian slash conspiracy thinking
conspiracy adult Echo chamber where
um the non-standard version of
everything is is almost certainly the
right account right so
no one can be trusted all you all you
really can
it is a kind of um
it's a kind of religion of of suspicion
that is that is being born it's like
it's it's a pseudo-awakening of
they're all Liars right like
that's this that's what happened to so
many millions of people during covet
they're all liars I mean just got Gavin
Newsom closing the beaches and then he's
he's over at French Laundry you know
perfectly quaffed uh at a fundraiser is
that hypocrisy that people found I mean
that was just a 20 Megaton moment of
hypocrisy that detonated and
it broke trust with with half the
country you know and and so it's
again that's all understandable but
we have to be realistic about just what
is true and likely to be true in each
moment and is everything the CDC says
likely to be wrong right like is that is
that really where is that what we want
to default to you can't trust the CDC
about anything is that how you really
want to be a consumer of medicine it
just is completely unworkable what we
need is a CDC we can trust and insofar
as we don't truly have that then that is
where we have to perform surgery but
it's not like we can tear it all down
and then we're just going to chat GPT
our way to health it's just it's not
going to happen we'll get back to
talking to Simon one minute but first I
need to tell you about element element
is the way that I've started my day
every single morning for over three
years now it is the best hydration drink
that I've ever found there's no gluten
no fillers no artificial junk or any
other BS it tastes phenomenal that
orange salt flavor is absolutely
outstanding it'll help to regulate your
appetite it'll curb Cravings it'll
improve brain function and it means that
you don't need to have a coffee first
thing in the morning your adenosine
system that caffeine acts on isn't even
active for the first 90 minutes of the
day but salt acts on your adrenal system
an element contains a science back
electrolyte ratio of sodium potassium
and magnesium they also have a no BS no
questions asked refund policy where you
can buy it 100 risk-free and if you do
not like it for any reason they'll give
you your money back and you don't even
need to return the Box head to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom how far do you think RFK
gets in this political race
um well if I'm
I'm hopeful that if he keeps expounding
upon how you know covid was targeted to
avoid Ashkenazi Jews and and Chinese
people and I mean it's like if you if
you give him a mic enough he will put
his foot you know he'll put both feet in
his mouth and and in your mouth and in
any mouth that's available I mean it's
just it's
um but again it's not that he's wrong
about everything he's that it's it's
harder than that right he's he is right
about many things and and the fact that
people love what he's saying
is totally understandable that's it's
just not you know half truths are harder
to deal with and or or
statements which are riddled with truths
but the cut the general shape of them is
wrong and and aiming in the wrong
direction like that is just it's hard
for people to parse that stuff
um and it's especially hard when
occasionally The Conspiracy Theory turns
out to be true or very likely to be true
it's like if you're if you're a person
who hasn't
an appetite for every conspiracy theory
right so JFK wasn't you know couldn't
have been a single shooter and you're
just you've just bought everyone since
then
then you're going to be then when you
know covid will likely escaped a lab in
Wuhan
if you're the first person to sign up to
that in an environment where everyone's
being called racist for signing up to
that you're going to look like this
contrarian genius who just like I they
couldn't fool me right I knew that it
likely came out of a lab
um whereas the the rational position to
have had I mean you have to take all of
these things a la carte right like you
just have to honestly investigate
um you know within the
confines of um
opportunity costs and and
bandwidth you you have to investigate
them
um as they come and I mean with that one
in particular it was always obvious that
it was at the very least plausible that
covid could have escaped a lab we just
know we have a problem with lab leaks
and there's a there was the Wuhan
Institute for virology right there
working on coronaviruses it was never
raised it was that was that was a woke
shibboleth to call that racist
to worry that it could come out of a lab
should have spoken a royal breed I would
have made Asian
uh which Rob Reed is that that did after
run didn't he do a big oh right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I I was
thinking about the uh the Christian
Robert yeah so no so Rob and I did a
podcast on this kind of topic you know
lab leaks in general and synthetic bio
in general
um
but
again that you can't give so if someone
like RFK Jr likes all the conspiracies
like every one of them he likes the
you know cell phones cause glioblastoma
you know idea which again it's totally
possible right it's like it's not that
it's not worth looking into but if you
like that one and you like the Bill
Gates microchipping one and you like the
the Wuhan one and you like that covet
itself was just a pandemic and you and
you like all of these and you like the
Ashkenazi Jews don't get coveted you
just have it's a characterological
problem you have this appetite for I
mean you see this the the true Avatar of
this way of thinking is someone like
Alex Jones right like again I don't know
if Alice Jones is just a performance
artist and it's it's cynical and not not
real or if he really believes what he
says he believes but assuming he
believes what he says he believes
he is just
yeah you know it's like you're an a
nymphomaniac for and what you love is
lies right and half truths right you
like you like you just love the least
credible ideas you know the the whatever
can come over the transom that's what
gets you hard right and so that you're
just gonna keep doing that and it's a
it's a disorder right but it's you know
if it's true that certain frogs are
getting turned gay right like and you're
the first one talking about that well
he was right about those frogs so he
must be right about everything you're
going to find an audience and the the
what's so perverse about our current
environment online is that
there is no evolutionary real
evolutionary pressure anymore
because everything can succeed there's
just a nut there's a there's always you
can always just find another corner of
the internet
and another Echo chamber and just this
part of 4chan and a 4chan isn't good
enough for you it can be over at a Chan
right like you can find this little hell
hole where every where you're gonna a
requisite number of people to monetize
ultimately
are willing to hear and talk about
anything and
foreign so I I unlike many of the people
we just spoke about I'm convinced that
we have an enormous problem with
misinformation that is held in tension
with our desire for free speech on every
topic you know 24 hours a day
that we have to take seriously we have
to say and it is it's not that we should
ever write a law which which says people
have to go to jail for saying crazy
things I think the First Amendment truly
is
sacred and the right it's just beyond
sacred it's just the right algorithm to
have for it to run a democracy and and
you know we have it in America and
almost no one no one else has it but
that's not the same thing as having a
right to
the gamification
algorithm that boosts the craziest stuff
preferentially to the ends of the Earth
and maintains it
forever right and that and and now you
add generative AI to that and I think
the problem just gets worse so yeah I'm
I'm worried about consequential lies and
half truths in a way that many of my
colleagues in podcast and aren't getting
back to something which is less
contentious perhaps death and the fact
that we
maybe should spend more time thinking
about it or at least be a little bit
more aware of it I want to read a quote
from that presentation that you gave on
death in the present moment
as a matter of conscious experience the
reality of your life is always now and I
think that this is a liberating truth
about the nature of the human mind in
fact I think there's probably nothing
more important to understand about your
mind than that if you want to be happy
in this world the past is a memory it's
a thought arising in the present the
future is merely anticipated it is
another thought arising now what we
truly have is this moment and this and
we spend most of our Lives forgetting
this truth refuting it fleeing it
overlooking it and the horror is that we
succeed we manage to never really
connect with the present moment and find
fulfillment there because we are
continually hoping to become happy in
the future and the future never arrives
it is always now however much you feel
you need to plan for the future to
anticipate it to mitigate risks the
reality of your life is now even when we
think we're in the present moment we are
in very subtle ways always looking over
its shoulder anticipating what's coming
next we're always solving a problem and
it's possible to Simply drop your
problem if only for a moment and enjoy
whatever is true of your life in the
present
you say that your mind is all you have
just before that
what does that mean reflecting on that
statement now what what did you hope
that people took away from it
well it's
there's this
we've spoken about it a little bit
already there's this fundamental truth
that
you never truly arrive if you're if your
attention is always purposed toward
looking for the next thing anticipating
the next thing
uh if even
in the presence of that very thing that
was the next thing and now it's now you
are busy
telling yourself a story about it you
know you're if your engagement with it
is mediated by thought in each moment
and you can't actually make contact
whether you can't you can't
there's there's this dissatisfaction
even in satisfaction right you get the
thing you were longing for and
you you have such a you're so
distractible you're so you're so
burdened by
this automaticity of thought this
conversation you're having with yourself
that
the present moment it isn't even Salient
enough to you right and so it's it's a
um
most of us most of the time live in that
kind of you know we get buffeted between
the past and anticipate in the future
and thinking about the past and that
flicker happens over even the present
moment right I mean we're just we're
just you know like I mean even in a
conversation like this like I'm saying
something if part of my attention is
women have I gone on too long about this
or it's like hit like did that even make
sense what was it there's part of me
that is that is potentially talking to
myself about the very conversation we're
having now now
that is all too normal everyone is in
that position I mean people are people
who are listening to us now are
struggling to follow my train of thought
as I speak one because I'm long-winded
but two it's my speech is competing with
speech that there is is occurring to
them in their head right they're saying
what's he talking about oh Jordan didn't
say that what is he where does he get
off talking about Jordan now and there's
someone in their head who seems
to be them but strangely not them
because if they're the one talking and
also listening why are they having that
conversation in the first place right
this is this
people are looking over their own
shoulder into the even when they're
trying to seize the present with both
hands right even if they take my advice
in that quote and say okay I got to be
all about that now right
the future never arrives there's just
now so let's enjoy the now what they
will find is they lack the tools to
really do that and so one tool
again is something something like
psychedelics right you take the
requisite dose of LSD or psilocybin or
MDMA again these are potentially very
different experiences but they're
they're what will happen under the Aegis
of any of those compounds is
very likely you will have a full
collision with the present moment of A
Sort that you have never had before if
it's your first time on one of those
drugs and all of a sudden the the your
sensory experience and your concept even
your conceptual experience will begin to
unfold and you will realize there is
just much more here than I than you
realize right like like everything
becomes
a kind of miracle and
the problem with that is that
finding meaning in everything
is crazy right you become the guy who's
just like like you know if I'm staring
at this microphone I'm so I come here
stoned and I'm just like oh my God that
microphone is just that you know that's
not the guy you want on your podcast
right so
but it is possible it
the
it is possible to to fall into The Well
of being such that the present moment
the present moment lacks for nothing
right you're just you recognize that
love what you meet what you really mean
by love what you should mean by love is
not this transactional thing that you
get going with a specific person because
of your shared history together and
because of their qualities that you
happen to like
um it is actually a state of being that
you can just plunge into and you
recognize that this is
the the point of life is to is to
recognize this more and more right and
so and love is one facet to the to this
Jewel compassion is another just
just awe you know is is another I mean
it gets different shadings depending on
the environment you put it in I mean
it's like if you're in the presence of
of human or animal suffering well then
compassion is the thing that gets
Amplified
but in the sign in in real silence and
in in a real
undistracted collision with the present
moment when you don't have this voice in
your head diverting you uh or coming up
from behind seeming to be you right like
but what happens is
people feel like a
a separate self I mean here perhaps I
should rewind for a second that this
here's the here's the starting point for
99.9 percent of humanity people feel
like a self people feel like they're
they're a subject
in the middle of their experience right
they feel like they're having an
experience they feel like they're
they're on the edge of experience in
some sense they don't feel like they
don't feel identical to experience right
so I'm so and experience is you know
your five sensory channels and your mind
right so you've got your scene hearing
smelling tasting touching thinking
feeling emotions
and you've got this whole
cacophony of what it's like to be you in
each moment
and sometimes it's very very pleasant
and sometimes sometimes it's very
unpleasant and sometimes it's just you
know
uh
normal and there's nothing really
especially Salient about it
um and the default sense is
to feel like a self in the middle of
that right and
it's that
it's that starting point that is
actually the basis for all of our
dissatisfaction and psychological
suffering I mean that is the that is the
knot that has to be untied
to that that really allows for a
recognition of what the mind is like
prior to identification with thought and
prior to
this fee this this capture by this this
automatic this reflexive seeking and not
finding operation that we're we're
constantly engaged with so
um
yeah it's possible to so yes
on some level you know certainly
spiritually speaking now is everything
there really is just Consciousness in
his contents in each moment right and
and there's there's never a reason to
wait to recognize that right
um this isn't to disavow all the other
projects we can have in human life that
take some time to accomplish right I'm
not saying you everyone should just
become a monk or go to a cave and starve
I mean like there are things that I like
to do in the world and want to get done
and I have projects but in each moment
the question is what is available to
attention
uh and why do you suffer right and if
you if you
if you're going to ask yourself why do
you suffer in each moment why why is
this moment just a little crappy right
why is it just not good enough why am I
looking forward to this thing in an hour
and I'm unable to locate a real ease of
being now you know before this good
thing happens
um before this uncertainty gets resolved
right before I hear from the doctor that
I don't have the thing that I'm worried
about what do you like all of these
contingencies
what's available now what you find is
and you know meditation is the ultimate
answer to this in my view
you find is this this on the on the part
of virtually everyone this basic
incapacity to break the spell of
identification with thought and just
rest attention
as Consciousness in the present moment
and meditation is simply the act of
doing that ultimately there are many
techniques that that can seem like
something other in the beginning but
ultimately if it works
meditation is the ability to to look at
this thing you thought was your ego with
that you thought was yourself that you
thought was the homunculus that was in
the middle of your experience
and not find it and not find it in a way
that actually relieves you of the
problem of egocentricity for that moment
right it might only last in the
beginning
it might only last a moment right and
then you'll be lost in thought again but
that but the question is once you learn
to meditate
the question is always what do you do
next and if you don't know how to
meditate well you're just going to
helplessly be thinking that thought and
you'll think it for as long as you'll
think it and it'll you know make you
angry or sad or regretful or whatever
depending on its contents and then
you'll try to have to figure out how to
rearrange your life on the basis of that
thought so it's to not be angry or sad
or regretful but when once you know how
to meditate you can recognize thoughts
as thoughts and they just arise and
disappear in this wider space of
awareness and you locate your well-being
in that space as as that space
but but if all of that sounds like
religious gibberish that is of totally
interested in
and it would have seemed that way to me
when I was 18 the only thing for a
hard-headed skeptic uh much of the time
is an experience that snaps you out of
your egocentric Illusions for some
period of time and so for me Peru goes
to Peru go to Peru or um um I which I
haven't done I haven't done Ayahuasca
but for me psychedelics weren't they
they were indispensable because
I was someone it had you
confronted me as an undergraduate in
college with whatever I just said
I would have even if I had been
convinced to try meditating for an hour
I wouldn't have had the aptitude for it
that such that I would have immediately
noticed there was there was a there I
would have I would have bounced off I
would have got the sense that
it didn't work for me I got you most
people
you know someone like or someone like
Richard Dawkins is a perfect example
it's like I I am bushed him on my
podcast with you know five minutes of
meditation and I thought you're gonna
say spiked the drink with yeah he no
Richard
I told Richard he should he should do
psychedelics
um
but
most people who are especially and this
is especially true of hard-headed
rationalist skeptic scientist types
um they're so enamored of thought
thought is the only appendage they have
ever found by which to or by which to
interface with reality such that they
can't imagine a mind prior to thought
they can't imagine a non-conceptual
engagement with reality that reveals
anything you know it sounds like what do
you it sounds like brain damage right
like my concepts are great like you
should have Concepts as good as my
Concepts right why what are you okay
you're going to hit me on the head with
a hammer yeah then I'll have fewer
Concepts right but
so when you point them inward when you
say okay just just notice that like just
try try to focus on your breath for 10
seconds and notice how hard that is
notice what happens notice that you get
carried away by something that you are
not authoring right like you're did you
decide to get distracted about what's
going to happen for lunch uh when I just
told you to pay attention to your breath
and you were on it for two seconds and
now you're thinking about lunch like
does that does that know is that at all
interesting to you that that's the
hardest thing in the world
so just pay attention to anything
some people find that interesting some
people find that that's a there's a sort
of an intimation of a path there like
okay maybe there's something to discover
here that could provide some relief to
something that is in fact ailing me but
for many people not and then if you give
those people
some psychedelic experience
many of them recognize oh okay there is
a there I don't know how I don't know if
this one is optimal this is just this is
just different
but it's so different
and some of it is so pleasant and some
of it is so
undermining of the that I
generally find so captivating
that this is a Counterpoint to how I've
been living my life right and so I need
I need to I need more tools and that's
how many of us have got into meditation
what is the role
of
feeling in this whatever term you want
to call it the embodiment of emotions
the tapping into some sort of intuition
because I I resonate a lot with the
cerebral horsepower model uh relying on
whatever it is cognitively that I've got
that I can deploy on the thing that's in
front of me and I take a lot of pride in
that and I think a lot of people do a
lot of the people they'll be listening
to this podcast listen to your podcast
will feel the same you know we we take
pride in our ability to
Wrangle the chaos of the world into some
sort of order by by thinking through
things and taking Concepts from
different disparate areas and bringing
them together and going wow that's
really satisfying I Now understand the
way that these two things could result
in this third thing and that third thing
is
but it does to me in some ways
feel
a little like a prison and it's a almost
a prison of your own making and it's one
that you're proud of you stand there
with this gilded prison wall and
everything's coded in in the toilet's
gold and the floor's gold and
there's an Open Sky and all this stuff
um
what's the role of allowing some sort of
embodiment or emotion or or feeling to
come back into this to allow the
cerebral stuff to slip away but not to
just be completely blank to be able to
to hear what you're sort of truly
feeling in the moment
yeah well it
meditation I mean so the kind of
meditation I recommend is is generally
called mindfulness and it's
in the initially it seems like a
technique and it's taught as a technique
but ultimately it's not a technique it's
not a it's not something you're doing
more of it's you're actually doing less
of something which is
You're simply not being distracted by
thought and so when you have a feeling
when you feel Joy or you feel sadness
mindfulness is
it's often thought of especially when
you're talking about negative feelings
that people classically want to get rid
of or diminish like anxiety right
it's often thought that mindfulness is a
way of getting rid of those feelings
right and It ultimately it is but it's
not a way of getting rid of them by
born of an unwillingness to feel them
right like what you're doing when you're
being mindful of an emotion
is you're willing to as you're feeling
it entirely you're feeling it deeply
you're letting yourself become
incandescent with that feeling you're
just not thinking about it anymore and
and it's not that you're blocking
thoughts you're just noticing thoughts
themselves arise along with the feeling
but you're noticing them from the point
of view of this prior condition of
awareness they can just see
thoughts as thoughts right the default
case is to not know that you're thinking
even if you could say that you know that
you're thinking in each moment a thought
is is coming up from behind and you just
feel like it's you and you're thinking
about the thing that's making you angry
and that's making you angry and so
you're feeling anger and then you're
thinking about the thing that's making
you angry and that I can't
believe what was he thinking and that's
the voice in your head and that feels
like you right like that you have no
perspective is that not you no it's no
more than than
these these sounds are you when you hear
them right like literally it is it is
like being asleep and dreaming I mean
that's why many people you I you know
I've titled my book and my app waking up
and what you know this is an ancient
analogy which is all too literal
breaking the spell of thought is very
much like waking up from a dream when
you you just didn't know you were having
like you were you're asleep and dreaming
let's leave aside lucid dreams which are
a different case the normal case is
you're asleep and dreaming and you have
no idea what your situation is you are
you are convinced you're in a totally
different situation than you in fact are
you're actually safe and safely in your
bed
and yet you think
you're somewhere else you're you're out
of nightclub you're you know at the
office you're you know you're at the
doctors something and it could be an
emergency and it's completely imaginary
right it could have some point of
contact with your life but is completely
imaginary
and the amazing thing about dreams is
the transition from sleep from waking to
sleep to Dreaming is one in which we
never register a moment of surprise
right like like it's just it is amazing
that your mind is capable like you are
you go to sleep in your bed
and then the very next thing that
happens to you
as a conscious entity it's totally
discontinuous with what where you were
if in your memory 15 minutes ago and
where you in fact are in this moment
if the laws of physics have been
suspended you know dead people are now
walking I mean literally talking to
someone who's dead and you're not even
you might be surprised they're dead but
I had a dream a couple of days ago that
I'd committed a war crime and the old
cricket team that I used to play for 20
years ago was hunting me and I'm pretty
sure that you were there as a newscaster
so it makes perfect sense yes obviously
yeah but so but that that failure of
reality testing is something we are
guilty of in every moment that a thought
seems to be what we are where it seems
like our mind becomes identical to this
voice in our head where the self where
you just feel like
again you're listening to me you're not
on you're not you're not rocking what
I'm saying
the voice in your head says what is he
talking about was this is this Buddhism
or like what's what's this guy banging
on about look at that that is just
arising out of you know not where right
there's a total mystery at your
back and then you've got this language
and you in many cases imagery getting
piped in from you know
the uh you know stage right and stage
left and you can't you can't figure out
how to turn to see what where anything's
coming from where where are our thoughts
coming from it's utterly subjectively
speaking as a matter of experience it's
it's utterly mysterious right like they
they and once you break this spell once
you see it's very again it's very much
like waking up from a dream like once
you begin to wake up from a dream like
it could be as it could be as bad or as
seemingly consequential as possible
right you know you're on a battlefield
you're being prosecuted for you've been
chased as a war criminal right your
adrenaline is up the moment you begin to
your alarm goes off and the the dream
the dream the dream is so insubstantial
that in most cases
you can't even remember it right like it
could have been really intense and yet
it's so discontinuous with your normal
waking consciousness that when it when
it begins to erode
sometimes you can just get this wisp of
where was there a beach you know like
there's just nothing left and yet it was
all-encompassing when you were having it
this we liver a lot so
that strikes us as perfectly normal
because basically we all dream when
we're asleep and you know and it seems
fine most streams are fun or not but
no no real consequence we all live our
Awakening Lives having this conversation
with ourselves which is also totally
normal everyone's doing it and yet both
of these conditions being asleep and
dreaming and not knowing it and being
and thinking every moment of the day and
not really knowing it and certainly not
seeing any alternative to being
identified with thought
both of them are a kind of psychosis and
they really are say they're so close to
what we recognize in other in the
canonically crazy people as psychosis
right and so your thought
is only really different from psychosis
in that you have the good sense to keep
your mouth shut in public right like if
you were if you were helplessly
exteriorizing all of this conversation
you know just talking to someone who's
not there
um in the way that you're talking to
someone who's not there in the Silence
of your own mind you'd be the crazy
person on the street who's talking to
himself right it's not and I'm not
saying I'm not trivializing the tragedy
of psychosis I mean there's other things
going on there there's you know classic
thought disorder where you're you know
you find Alex Jones credible and you're
you know you're just every conspiracy
theory is in fact real
um but
we we have
we've all accepted a status quo of
more or less constant distraction by
this inner voice
and it's so it again it's universally
subscribed but it's not it's not what is
also universally subscribed is Frank
unhappiness and dissatisfaction and it
is the basis for our unhappiness and
dissatisfaction
why is everyone a voice so mean most of
the time it you know if we spoke to
friends or even strangers the way that
we often speak to ourselves yeah we'd
very quickly be on the receiving end of
something that we probably didn't enjoy
why is it that we have this
default not everyone but a lot of people
yeah it's default to to converse with
ourselves if that's even the correct
term uh in a way which is
horrible
well it can be very wise to notice that
and to notice that very different and to
just leverage that as a way of changing
your inner voice I mean like so this is
like your meditation is one thing
it's one remedy for for what ails us but
there are other tools and one and one
tool is to just note it notice what you
just noticed is that you would never
talk to your best friend the way that
you talk to yourself and you can learn
to talk to yourself the way you would
talk to your best friend and then you
your your mind is much more your friend
you know on some level
wisdom is a is a matter of making your
mind your friend right and there are a
few layers
that can be addressed to do that and one
is
that the non-conceptual layer of what
I'm calling meditation another is a
conceptual layer of just noticing the
character of this conversation
and noticing how
bizarre it is and contingent it is and
how how malleable it is ultimately like
the moment you recognize that you're not
you're not you don't have to change
yourself as a person like you you
wouldn't talk to your friend this way
like you're not this much of an you're
not not only you're not this much of an
to your friend you're not an
at all to your friend like like
when your friend is going if your friend
is going through the very thing you're
going through and beating yourself up
over
you know exactly what you would say
you would successfully say it you're not
not an imposter you wouldn't have to
fake saying it like you were just like
what would come out of you is a
compassionate like let's just figure out
how to how to improve the situation yeah
just like this is like there's regret is
is completely uh unhelpful like this
like you did the past has passed you
know you are you are a great competent
person who's got all kinds of tools
let's make the most of them let's just
you know
you've got this despondent horrible
voice that you give yourself and a kick
in the deck on the way out of the door
yeah I think I think I said it or wrote
at some point that you know to a first
approximation wisdom is is simply a
capacity to take your own advice right
like you you effortlessly give that
advice to others if you could just get
if you could just give it and
successfully receive it from yourself
you know you're basically Socrates
um but as to why it has a negative
character I don't know that it does I
mean I think some people
don't
have nearly the self-critical voice
that's familiar to many of us right so
there's just I think there's probably
something like a bell curve there where
some people have a fairly happy and even
somewhat happily delusional self-talk
and they're uh
you know they're a good company for
themselves you often talk about uh the
tension between being and becoming it
kind of feels a little bit like there's
something going on here
I'm fascinated with this
relationship between finding peace and
happiness and gratitude with what you
have
while asking for more from yourself and
and hoping that you can achieve to be
able to feel gratitude and drive at the
same time
why this to me feels like a Perpetual
challenge a Perpetual difficulty because
the drive to do more often not always
but often is driven from a sense of
insufficiency it's driven from a lack I
will be happy when so on and so forth
but
the
thought of going through life and just
leaving it all on the table because I'm
just in this state of sort of constant
orgasmic Bliss and I I don't
need to do anything anymore because I'm
I'm just blessed out man yeah
also doesn't sound particular and I I
struggle to achieve that no matter how
much yeah Tantra I try and
yeah to talk to me there's tension
between the drive to do more the
acceptance of who we are the wanting to
to show up in the world and to to give
it everything that we've got and the
gratitude for the things that we already
have
yeah well it is a constant tension and I
think you want to ultimately I think you
want to be biased on the the being
inside of it I mean certainly if you've
succeeded enough right like if you have
a
if you recognize that you've won the
lottery on some level and you
are in a position now where
there are billions of people who would
consider their prayers answered if they
could trade places with you right and
you you there'll be a time in your life
where
you would give anything to trade places
with who you who you are now right like
when you're you know when you're in your
last months of life and you're eternally
ill or you're you know you've lost
someone very close to you I mean there's
like when you have when you have this
moment in the sun where basically you're
basically things are basically going
well right
I think it's appropriate to have a
a module in your in your mind which
continually pings you which says like if
you can't enjoy this right like you know
if this is going to be wasted on you
you're never going to be happy right
like this is the you should be able to
enjoy this part like this this is this
is dessert right dessert has arrived and
you whatever story you have about all
the other things you might do or become
this is really like you know this is a
wonderful life right so can you
can you settle into this at all with
your attention right and if you can't
I think that's the problem to recognize
right like if like if the thing you
should want to become is someone who's
better at recognizing the beauty of your
life moment to moment right now there's
a paradox there that ultimately has to
be overcome right like the wanting to
become more spiritual wanting to wanting
to become a great meditator I wanted to
become enlightened that's you know a
a knot that that gets untied but
it's a fairly you know
refined one
um
but
it is it's just totally appropriate to
recognize this mismatch between
what is objectively true of your life by
reference by comparison to anything else
that's that is on the menu and the
general mediocrity of your way of being
you know just the feeling
I mean and so this is again this is this
is dual down to you not in big chunks
but in moments right like this is not
like the a grand plan like okay I got my
calendar out this month is going to be
about X and now I'm going to nail X
right it's much more
a thousand lessons over the course of a
day right like like you have to just be
attentive to
moments where you miss it
and moments where you and and then just
recognizing that it's invade it's
available now right like you were a
moment ago you were tied in a knot
somehow for some reason you know things
were awkward or weird and then and then
and now you're back right so like I was
I was coming to this interview
um and I was I was late I was 15 minutes
late you know and and I hate being late
for whatever reason and
um so I'm kind of rushing to get out of
the house and you know my wife has got
her own day ahead of her and she's
rushing to get out of the house and
we're sort of ping-ponging around each
other and we're kind of missing each
other and very in and out of the
bathroom in and out of the closet and
and
you I say goodbye to her but it was a
sort of a goodbye like you know I've
just completely missed her like this
beautiful woman who I've decided to
spend my life with and like like where
she's now just a basically an obstacle I
have to navigate around so this would be
you know 30 seconds earlier than I would
otherwise be if I just took a moment to
recognize how beautiful my life is right
so I missed I missed her I miss her I
missed her I missed her and then at the
penultimate moment as I'm grabbing my
keys I'm like
oh here she is right and so I just stop
her I give her a kiss and then I leave
right and it's just the difference
between finding that moment and not is
enormous right and it's just it's it's
like the area under the Curve
could still suck a lot from it's like in
the beginning you might only have 20
moments like that a day right but the
difference between being someone who
never gets it clearly right and it never
truly punctuates his busyness and
ambition and disappointment and
everything every other you know module
that's been installed with just clear
you know
clear contact with the beauty and
sacredness of the present moment
that difference is is enormous and once
you have those
those punctate moments and again this is
a meditation by another name
then you can have a hundred and then you
can have a thousand and then and then
then the character of your life can more
and more resemble
the true Virtues Of Being
even when you're still becoming and even
when you have the whole apparatus of
you've got employees you've got a
calendar you've got slack is open all
day it's like it's all that's happening
you can still be someone who's
basically already happy right you're
like you're not leaning forward
so much and when you do our leaning
forward
part of you recognizes okay what's this
about like like you have a kind of
mindfulness alarm that goes off when
you're when you're obviously expecting
to become Happy by the next thing
right
rather than be truly taken in by that
dream
part of you knows okay wait a minute
like just set this just correct your
posture a little bit like you know that
no matter how good this dinner is it's
just going to be a dinner right and then
you're going to be too full and then
you're going to wish you hadn't eaten
all that and then you then you're going
to find it hard to sleep and then and
that so like you you know that there's
it can't be a matter of of reaching and
grabbing and and fully
uh satisfying your desire again and
again and again as a as a
a way to finally become happy there's
got you have to find locate your
satisfaction more and more in just the
in in the state of being that is already
here that's preceding the next change
your debt your happiness can't be
ultimately a matter of changing
experience it has to be a matter of
recognizing
the nature of experience now
that it can be you know
very easy to have a cynical take on that
and say okay well it's easy for you to
say a rich white guy who for whom
everything's going great and nothing bad
has yet happened and the worst thing
that happened to you was on Twitter and
so go yourself
but no first of all many bad things have
happened I know what it's like to lose
someone close to me I know what it's
like to worry that your your kid is
really sick I know what it's like to be
waiting for the MRI like like all these
moments where
you know even even the luckiest among us
know what it's like to to live in the in
with real uncertainty and the knowledge
that
you know ultimately
every bad thing some version of every
bad thing is going to happen I mean even
if you're the luckiest and healthiest
and richest you know then you're just
going to be sitting by the phone you
know hearing that all your friends have
died right like if you live to be 120 in
perfect health you know you're you're
Peter attia and you've you've uh you
know you're still doing kettlebells at
120 which I hope you keep them in yeah
yeah I hope you are Peter and Andrew
um then you're just going to be getting
you know
voicemails and texts and whatever else
exists at that point hearing that all
these people you loved have disappeared
right so no one gets out of here without
real a real encounter with with Greek
level tragedy and
the question is is it possible to have a
mind
that can Embrace that with Equanimity
and compassion and love and
tranquility
or do you just have to to pretend none
of that's going to happen
the normal mode is to to try to be lucky
enough
so that you can pretend hard enough and
long enough that none of that
applies to me right like I'm just gonna
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna stay
healthy for as long as I can stay
healthy I'm not going to think about
cancer until somebody has cancer like
it's like I'm just I'm gonna extract as
much pleasure as I possibly can in the
moment and you know look that Bugatti
over there is mine right you know so
it's like that's
at best that's impermanent right even if
that was as satisfying as as someone
could pretend and we actually know it's
not and you can know that from the
inside the more you have those
experiences
the
it's impermanent you know I mean it's
like a certain point Andrew Tate is
going to be the the 80 year old with bad
tattoos right like it's just not it's
like it's it's not it doesn't scale like
like that you need you need a another
gear
and
there are many names for this I mean
wisdom is one name spirituality
um
Enlightenment Awakening
meditation and all of these Concepts you
know psychedelic experiences all of
these tools and concepts are
triangulating on a part of the map where
one's well-being isn't contingent upon
changes in experiences there's a
recognition
that is possible about the nature of of
conscious life itself that is fulfilling
giving ourselves a good enough reason to
just be here in the present moment yeah
yeah this would both
fans and friends with Paul Bloom and uh
yeah Paul managed to draw the perhaps
surprising correlation between this and
a dominatrix that he'd interview yes he
would yeah he he uh he's he's great with
surprising correlations yeah and um it
really made me it really made me realize
because I think it's in maybe the death
and the present moment talk that you
gave us something else that a lot of
what we're doing externally with the way
that we try and show up in the world
the way that we construct our exterior
lives and our experience is to give us a
good enough reason to just be here now
yeah and people find this through
staring at the night sky people find it
through going to Raves and Collective
effervescence they find it through and
Paul gave me this reason I interviewed a
dominatrix for one book the one in pain
maybe and um
she'd said nothing captures attention
like a whip right which means that if
you get slapped hard by a lady
presumably in
bicep length Gauntlet leather gloves
high knee boots and stuff
if you get slapped by her
for the next three seconds you're
thinking about nothing apart from the
fact she just slapped me yeah and you're
just hearing that ringing in your ears
and that's it and I think that the way
that I've conceived of it I wrote this
on a beach whilst kind of high on
mushrooms but I wrote it on a beach that
the goal of a lot of mindfulness and the
goal of a lot of what we're doing with
our life should be to lower the bar
to which we need the world's
external stimulus to be in order for us
to feel happy it should be as Naval says
if you won't be happy with the coffee
you won't be happy on a yacht right yeah
and continue to just
that whatever the reverse of progressive
overload is yeah Progressive underload
yes yeah yeah and just continue to Chip
Away chip away I can find it when I'm
washing the dishes I can find it when
I'm walking the dog I can find it when
I'm
etc etc waiting in traffic
yeah and
if that seems difficult uh
it certainly can be but that doesn't
mean it's not possible and and
The crucial point is that you have to
recognize what the alternative is right
the alternative is just bad the
alternative is to not be happy to be
incapable of Happiness even when you
have every reason to be happy right it's
it's the alternative is to be
not all that loving even when you're
surrounded by people you ostensibly love
right because you have a mind that is
constantly fragmented you're constantly
looking elsewhere you're constantly
waiting for the next thing you're
constantly ruminating about that last
thing and
you become bad company for the people in
your life who you really want to
to
whose lives you you know when in your
clear moments you really want you want
you just want to magnify happiness in
their presence right this is what I
think is is an important leap and I I
think that you make it very well in
waking up which I told you before we'd
started I think I've gifted my mum every
Christmas for the last three years which
has been a great assistance in me being
able to get something delivered
digitally the Night Before Christmas
when I've left it too late yeah early
annually
um I highly highly recommend that
everyone go and check it out
um
taking it from
an abstract
wishy-washy this is something that's
gonna maybe my anxiety will be a little
bit better maybe I won't feel my anger
anymore to uh as David Fuller says does
it grow corn like show me if it grows
any corn right like what does
this do for me to me to my life to the
relationships I have to fundamentally
the things that I care about the most
and the texture of our own minds is not
nothing in fact you could argue maybe
it's everything but there is something
beyond that too and I think that the
thin end of the wedge is getting people
in through the door that oh look at what
this could do to your world and then the
worlds of the people that you care about
and then think about how that could
Ripple out if you want to be super
altruistic and and the town and the
country and the the planet that you're
on and so on and so forth but
that is
that is the reminder when I've missed my
meditation streak for too long that I
get embarrassed about it and I I need to
I need to come back to using your app or
the timer or whatever
that's the reminder for me that gets me
through the door A lot of the time yeah
it's and I'm hesitant I came up with an
idea the other day uh productivity
Purgatory which is the things that you
do that are supposed to be recuperative
are done only to make you more
productive so you kind of have this
Perpetual existence of everything I did
Pickleball I play is because I heard
Andrew human say on a podcast that you
know 45 minutes of Zone 2 cardio per
week it helps me be able to focus better
and Peter attia told me that I've got to
go for a walk in the morning because of
my my glucose tolerance or whatever
um
trying to not just do that but you know
you can be driven by whatever it is to
get you I think to get the activation
energy to get it moving and for me
that's
that that's one of the most robust ways
to remind me like think about how it's
going to change the nature of your daily
experience internally and how you're
going to show up for other people
externally I think that that's a a leap
which
a modern version of of mindfulness and
then tying it in with the life advice
not just being about the mindfulness
it's like look look at the
things that you're struggling with look
at the things that you're challenged by
now the fact that you ruminate you have
regrets and shame and insufficiency and
Terror and fear and all that
this there is an alternative experience
of this and the way that this allows you
to show up in the world can also benefit
from it too yeah and also there's no
boundary between this thing we're
calling meditation or mindfulness and
the rest of one's life right I mean that
that boundary is truly spurious and it's
it's it's an artifact of you know first
learning not knowing the thing then
learning it then setting aside 10
minutes a day or whatever to practice it
or you go on a silent Retreat for a
month and then you come back to your
life and that there seems to be this
difference between life and retreat but
in reality is all you have is your mind
in each moment and you're either
suffering or not you're either lost in
thought or not you're either clearly
aware of of what it's like to be you or
not and
that
fluctuation is that that's really the
the ground of this practice or these
insights and that that's where wisdom is
and
um
so it's not you know I would encourage
people from the very beginning to view
the practice as
not at all being separate from the rest
of their day it's like like and you
don't in my view you don't get any
credit I mean there are consequences to
practicing or not practicing you know
for most people but
it's like you don't get credit for
having
meditated earlier today like I don't
give myself like if I sat for 20 minutes
yeah it's not like you Bank those 20
minutes and now you're good to go for
the rest of the day it's like the rest
of the day is your pre is your practice
right like your your life is your
practice you're on some level your life
is
a meditation it's just your your paying
attention to a thousand different things
but in each moment your attention is
being drawn and being dedicated to
something and you are you are making
your mind you're making your being in
the world based on how you pay attention
and meditation is just this period in
the day where you've decided okay for
these 10 minutes I'm going to give
myself permission not to think about
anything else other than just paying
attention
but
ultimately once you see the power of It
ultimately your entire life becomes that
even though you have to do other things
right so you're doing like if I'm if I'm
having this conversation I'm fluctuating
between being totally lost and clearly
seeing the nature of my mind in this
moment right so it just it keeps it's
it's absolutely no different from what
I'm doing if I set aside set aside 20
minutes to meditate right it's just it's
it's the same mind it's the same
challenge of noticing thought as thought
noticing emo you know clearly noticing
emotions and their linkage to thought
um
letting go of any uh
grasping at what's Pleasant or pushing
what's unpleasant away and through the
judgment and the contraction around
experience
as you pay attention to your mind you
notice that that you you tend to stay
in one of two types of contract of
contractedness your your
things are Pleasant and you're trying to
squeeze more goodness out of it right so
it's like oh yeah finally the good taste
and you're you're you're you're
contracted in avarice essentially
um and when things are unpleasant you're
you're pushing them away you're trying
to change you're bracing yourself
against the physical pain or the
embarrassment or the and again
mindfulness is just
they wide open non-judgmental
willingness to feel
both of those things and so you're so
it's if you can even step back on the on
the contraction like you can feel what
you're doing what you're disposed to do
with the feeling tone of pleasure or the
feeling tone of of pain and you and you
you recognize that all of that's
happening just against this clear mirror
of awareness and you drop back and
you're and all of a sudden
it's all floating free of that which is
aware of it and you're just that
condition of open receptivity
and you just keep falling back into that
it's not to say you don't get caught
trying to get some more pleasure out of
that thing or you're trying to change
this this painful thing but
the more you notice that fluctuation the
more you notice that real relief
is in not successfully doing either
these two things but in just recognizing
you're the mirror of awareness and the
the beautiful and ugly things are just
going to keep coming it's one of the
places where mindfulness gets closer to
stoicism I think I thought Marcus
Aurelius quote about the universe itself
is change and life is but what we deem
it yeah the story that we tell ourselves
I think you've got a an example that I
use all of the time even in my own life
um for the people that do CrossFit or
presenting Jiu Jitsu or hardcore
pickleball the way that you feel at the
end of one of those workouts where you
can taste metal in the back of your
throat and your heart rate's high and
you're sweating and you're panting and
it's 105 degrees in Austin Texas or
wherever
that sensation is associated with the
story that you tell yourself that this
is worthwhile that this is good for me
that this is something that I can feel
proud of but if you were to have that
sensation spontaneously stood in line at
the bank it would be pushing through the
to the get the teller to call the
ambulance because this is
terrifying so very much the story that
we tell ourselves around the present
moment largely determines our experience
of it
yeah and that that's another example of
a sort of a conceptual layer at which
you can do a lot of wise work in
changing your experience by using
certain kinds of Concepts as an antidote
to other bad Concepts so you tell
yourself a better story so reframing is
is just a very good technique but it's
sort of a layer above the mindfulness
layer of just noticing
that they're all just stories right and
and there's no place for them to land
right so and I think you people should
intelligently engage both levels I'm not
discounting the power of reframing or
and stoicism is fantastic I mean there's
you know Bill Irvin this philosophy
Professor um who wrote a great book the
guide to the good life
um has attract has a series on waking up
that is really great
um and so you know I'm kind of late to
the
stoicism as a you know I discovered it
when more or less everyone else did in
the last 10 years but you know I hadn't
read
Seneca or Marcus Aurelius you know one
even even when I got a Philosophy degree
back in the day
um and uh it's it's incredible just as
an operating system for your mind it's
very just a very few tools you need
um
and what you know one we just talked
about here briefly on attributed but
just like negative visualization just
recognizing how happy you would be to
really like you're in this normal state
of dissatisfaction recognize how much
you would pay to be returned to this
crappy little spot you're in now that
you're not enjoying if all of these
other bad things that had happened that
are happening to someone right now and
it just you're lucky enough that it's
not you the things that you're ignoring
now or taking for granted yeah the
cancer diagnosis you're not getting
today previously just things that you
wished that you once had yeah and yet
you're able to continue to adapt to this
what do you disagree with stoicism about
is there anything that stands out why
you think I'm not on board with that
well I think it had it probably has a
two
um
I'm not sure their view of our emotional
lives is something I would want to sign
on to in every respect I mean there's
kind of a detached from the decapitation
of your child yeah there's a kind of a
freeze of your business there's a
there's a fundamental Detachment that um
I'm not sure is the most interesting
channel to be on in the end
um I mean it can be very useful given
where we we normally live but um not so
rich but also it's just I
in my experience and make I'm not you
know I don't consider myself a true
scholar of stoicism but I don't I don't
think the stove I mean really the Greeks
in general lacked a methodology right
there are many of the insights that you
can recognize in Buddhism
you can also find among the Greeks not
just the stoics I mean maybe even more
so among the Skeptics
um
but they didn't really have a
methodology of training attention and
they and they didn't have a
a kind of a comprehensive
um marriage of
spiritual contemplative training and
ethical Insight that is as a is as
systematic and as useful as I found in
in Buddhism in particular so I I mean I
I'm a fan of other
Eastern uh Traditions as well but uh
again not in a religious sense but just
taking you know I'm very eclectic taking
what I think is useful and leaving the
rest but you know if you had to just go
to one shelf in the bookstore to find
you know to Pareto optimize the whole
spiritual journey you
you really can't do better than Buddhism
in my view I mean there's just there's
yes there's some there's certainly
some that should be ignored or
at least some stuff that's unjustifiable
that shouldn't be uh you know not too
much Faith should be placed in but
it's you could almost pick at random you
know like you go to 10 000 page Corpus
and just open it at random and you're
not gonna get
A Treatise on how to sacrifice a goat
right or why why you should kill
homosexuals you're going to get
something absolutely clear and totally
serviceable in the 21st century about
the nature of Consciousness I really
enjoyed Robert Wright's book yeah yeah
why Buddhism is true talking about
religion you spent a good part of your
career deconstructing religion yeah only
for it to then perhaps uh be replaced
with some similar religious thinking
around things like identity politics
yeah
was that was creating that vacuum and
error is there any way around this
it's religious thinking just baked into
our human I don't think it was the same
people necessarily I'm not sure
um
it is true that secularism and Atheism
seem to win many subscribers in the
interviewing years I don't know how much
can be attributed to the so-called new
atheist but
um
there was it
organized religion seems to have lost
many of his subscribers and it's you
know many of us perceive into that
vacuum people found meaning in politics
uh uh which is arguably
uh no more functional
um
yeah I mean I
I don't believe I mean I I find many
people will argue that
other people need X right they need
mythology they need religion they need
whatever
other people who you and I don't you and
I are smart enough successful enough we
got our heads screwed on straight we we
can get along fine with that X but other
people it's obviously millions and
millions people need eggs
I think that just shows a lack of
imagination and I mean it's it's
patronizing and I I fear it's actually
just not accurate for many many people
right it's like
who needs because you could do that with
anything like that all these people
millions of people need
to be confused about human health they
need to have like superstitions about
how to be healthy you and I can we can
deal with Biology and real medicine but
these people need
they need to believe that these bogus
pills really work right it's just
why would we think that right that's
it's in fact true that many people are
stuck in that spot and we have a is a
challenge to disabuse them of certain
bad ideas
um
but it's like does anyone need astrology
no no one needs astrology if we if we
categorically disproved astrology such
that it really landed for everybody
and all of these people sort of
staggered out of their you know dungeons
with this astrology shaped hole in their
lives that they had to figure out how to
fill
the problem just evaporates like they
would they they don't fill it with an
astrology-shaped object they would
actually just be disabused of the
astrology solution and they would go on
to believe and do other things now
it just so happens that
most of the time
we have we have we have strands of
culture where it's it's not only hard to
disabuse people with bad ideas it's
taboo to do it right so it's like
specifically with respect to religion in
in current politics with respect to
certain
um pieces of you know far left and Far
Right ideology you know I think more
more attuned with the far left at the
moment
um
it's just you know they're kind of
blasphemy tests in both spaces there's
you know there's dogmatism that goes
unexamined it's not it's not not only
unexamined it's in a religious context
it's a virtue that is dogmatic right I
mean the Dogma is literally a good word
in a religious context uh so like these
these are facts they're not going to be
we're not going to reconsider them any
demand that we reconsider them we're
going to consider a kind of violent
assault
um
we're gonna you know not only are we not
gonna talk to you really you know even
if we pretend to have a debate with you
we're gonna hate you and if we only had
enough power we would you know
physically subjugate you right
um sounds pretty religious that's that's
where so there are parts of culture
where we're stuck there but it just
doesn't seem the idea that it's
necessary that more people can't be like
us right just seems like a failure of
imagination to me I think I think that
everyone could have
a truly 21st century
non-sectarian relationship
to all ideas all possible projects all
invitations to collaboration we could
just deal with everything on its merits
and we could
Avail ourselves of all the world's
literature all the Legacy code
everything that's still serviceable
everything that's good
and if part of that is the Golden Rule
well yeah sure it is yeah the golden
rule is great but you don't have to
believe Jesus was the son of God or born
of a virgin to think the golden rule was
great I mean first you just recognize
the Golden Rule came from Jesus but it
also came in in the Old Testament it
came in other context I mean it's just
it's like the golden rule is just
an ethical Jewel that that many people
have have stumbled upon
we
we should just use the totality of human
knowledge in the present and to do that
honestly
requires that we not firewall certain
parts of that knowledge with these
dogmatic claims to you know divine
inspiration or you know you're a racist
if you even consider the possibility
that that uh you know a virus came out
of a lab right it's just
it's been interesting to me to watch
this especially because uh me and
Douglas Murray became friends just after
he wrote The Madness of crowds and in
that he's talking about the collapse of
grand narratives right he's talking
about the fact that people are latching
themselves on to ideological movements
political movements identity-based
movements to try and fill what he saw as
a a hole that had been left with this
this Grand narrative that came over the
top and um yeah it's interesting to me
to think that you know that book
15 years ago
would have kind of felt like like what
the are we talking about here we
have bigger fish to fry when it comes to
what people are ideologically kind of
addicted to which might have been more
in your wheelhouse and yet in the space
of no time at all this compulsion for
something yeah rather than nothing but I
mean there are other
variables I mean they're they're obvious
economic ones with the fact that
virtually all of the productivity games
in the last
really 50 60 years have gone to the top
10 percent in our society right
literally
I think it's um
92 percent of the stock market is owned
by the top 10 percent I think it's like
50 but by the top one percent right so
you know it's just 90 of people aren't
in the game
and not reaping the benefits of
modernity in an economic sense right and
they feel the the disad the obvious
dissatisfaction and you know one could
argue unfairness of that I mean our
system is not tuned to
to wisely
uh cause all boats or even most boats to
rise with with this particular tide or
that's just not I mean we got 10 of the
boats doing pretty great and then we got
one percent and then the top one you
know one percent of one percent doing
especially great and
this uh this kind of stratification
given
that so much of people's sense of how
they're doing so much of their you know
concept based estimation of their own
well-being and therefore their actual
experience well-being is comparative
right I mean they're they're not
and then the in many cases they're not
even
begrudging
you know Jeff Bezos on his yacht they're
just they're just noticing the
difference between
uh their life and the you know people
you know one who live one mile away
right it's like so so much of these
um
so when you price that in the
consequences of inequality wealth
inequality and income inequality
uh I think that could be enormously
agitating to people and also
give it can make certain in this case
you know populist narratives attractive
that would otherwise discredit
themselves because they're not
um
they're obviously not wise right like if
you don't have if you don't have skin in
the game right like the game if this
game is just not working well then of
course you want to upend the board right
I mean you'll you'll enjoy watching the
pieces fly all over the room because
this game this particular game of
Monopoly was not you didn't have
anything on Park Place right you know
none of that money was yours really it's
easy you know it's easy to see why many
many millions of people would be cynical
and just want to see they just want to
see change right they just want any
direction yeah they just don't want to
see a wrecking ball come through and
reset things and I I I you know credit
you know Trump and trumpism
as a you know a symptom of that you know
more than more than a cause really it's
just we were ready for that moment yeah
I think it's uh I think it's Warren
Buffett or Charlie Munger that says uh
we would be able to be happy if we just
wanted to do better but we don't we want
to do better than our next door neighbor
and it's this perpetual one-upmanship
and sort of keeping up with the Joneses
so I I agree that you know it's massive
wealth inequality causes Discord and
upset and perhaps primes the landscape
for people to want change regardless of
where it comes from right but I I'm
pretty sure that that continues all the
way down or all the way up as wealth
continues to increase it's one of the
reasons that I'm relatively skeptical of
Ubi because I I think that if you just
flatten the playing field you then start
to play games about people are going to
find people are going to find ways to do
status you know will store who wrote
that great great book for status game
you know does this tribe somewhere that
grows yams they grow massive yam these
unbelievably huge Yarns and after takes
four men to wheelbarrow these yams in
and I'm pretty sure that the what you do
is you give the yam to your greatest
enemy or something like that and it's
almost like it's like this yam shaped
middle finger that you're like I'm I'm
so rich I could I could forsake this
yeah precisely
um you know people will find ways
to compete the status and keeping up
with the Joneses is is is
they'd permeates an awful lot status is
a game that everybody is going to
continue to play
yeah
um
I mean I would recommend in that case I
would recommend
that we seek our status more and more in
being above that game now and that's not
as
absurd as it sounds right like you can
like if you can see
piece of the pieces of this in just how
very rich successful people already
start to behave like he's like you know
at a certain level of success like it's
important that you're wearing a suit and
you you know drive a nice car and you
have a nice watch and you have all those
signs of status but at a certain point
you know you show up in a hoodie because
you know everyone knows you know you're
they know you're you know they know
you're a billionaires yeah the richest
people drive to shittest cars right and
like at a certainly like I don't have a
guy just Uber you know I don't have a
car
now you can be cynical about all that
but
and you know some cynicism is
appropriate but there are benign four
forms of like if
I guess you could probably notice this
now happening around climate change and
private airplanes right like so it was
the case that the highest status
position with respect to travel is well
I've got a Gulf Stream you want to you
we'll just take my Gulf Stream you know
um
what could be better than that well
that's starting to erode the more stigma
gets attached to just squandering fuel
on a Gulf Stream right the more you're
you look like an for doing that
no matter what story you tell yourself
no matter how successful you are no
matter how much it saves your time you
sort of look like an on a Gulf
Stream
um
at a certain point you could imagine
that flipping and all of a sudden the
high the real high status thing is now I
just feel like commercials it's like you
know you can see Elon flying jet blue
and it's just yeah I just you know just
fly to it blue it's like and and it'll
be it will because it'd be because so
much punishment has been meted out on
the other side of like it just it no
longer looks cool to to be burning that
much fuel now
I'm hopeful that we do live in a world
of just really open-ended abundance
where yes there is actually no tension
between affluence and ethics in the end
right so that ultimately we're going to
get the right fuels we're going to power
this all with sunlight we're going to
have a high-tech Society where our
machines get better and better and we
start pull pulling wealth essentially
you know out of The Ether
um
let's leave aisi but you know it's a
success successful proliferation of AI
would be part of this I'm you know as
you know worried that we're going to
screw that up or that that isn't just in
fact too too hard a challenge but
um let's say we got that right
ultimately this could be a have your
cake and eat a two situation where it's
not a matter of
of
denying ourselves anything really
materially except
we should recognize that we there
there's certain degree certain
disparities of luck
that we find ethically intolerable right
like it's like just how
given that it currently and for the
longest time there is a zero-sum tension
between a dollar spent over here and a
dollar not spent over here
at just how comfortable should each of
us be with you know a Ginny coefficient
in our own society that just goes you
know goes asymptotic right like you know
like we're at one right like yes I've
got a trillion dollars but now my main
preoccupation is trying to figure out
how my compound in New Zealand is going
to be staffed with you know bodyguards I
can really trust yeah not to kill me and
yeah it's like the douglas douglas
rushkoff uh a conversation can you tell
me that story yeah so it's just like
yeah if that's where your mind goes you
should be spending much more time with
your billions and trillions figuring out
how to make a society where all you meet
when you walk out on the sidewalk are
other happy people and hap in your case
happy customers who are just doing
creative things in their free time you
know how much of a difference do you
think that would be over the last few
years in culture wars culture
discussions if Christopher Hitchens was
still alive
well it would silence all the morons who
think that he might have supported Trump
I think that's uh that would be that
would be worth resurrecting him just for
that just to see the look on their face
when he got him talking about Trump I
can't believe the people I've heard from
on that point
um yes he hated the clintons but there
is zero percent probability that he
would have had anything kind to say
about Trump
um
I don't I don't think it would have been
different it would have been wonderful
to have ridden shotgun with him on many
of these topics I mean he was you know I
I'm I'm a fan
uh as well as a friend but
um
I don't you know
I mean he was a he was enough of a um
an old dog uh who would have been hard
enough to teach New Tricks I'm not sure
he would have been
lighting up Twitter the way many people
might hope I mean maybe but he's um
yeah I mean he's much more like someone
who would have for the longest he he was
not an early adopter in any sense you
know it's like he just
uh he barely could barely do email in
the in a normal way right so it's just
it's um
yeah I think he would
I mean many of us are in this spot I
mean many of us who are much more early
adopters and more Tech enabled than he
ever was
um
you know we there's a kind of a
Nostalgia for books and old models and
some of us are trying to figure out how
to return to that in new ways right so
um
yeah I mean he loved literature so much
and and print so much that I think he
would be he would still be clinging for
dear life to shelves of books and a
business model that tries to prioritize
physical books basically every other way
of doing what what about the way what do
you think he would have made of the the
state of cultural discourse at the
moment knowing what you knew about him
well I think he would have found maybe
he would have been in this
uncharacterizable Middle where half the
time you're recognizing all that's wrong
and masochistic and insane about
wokeness uh and all that's wrong and
sadistic and dangerous in trumpistan and
just taking each each difficult object
as it comes right you know I think he
would be
um
I mean perhaps I flatter myself but I
think he would be very much in my Lane
with certain exceptions I mean certain
things that I'm very interested in and
and which I prioritize which he never
saw the point of much of was which we
talked about here I mean meditation
spirituality psychedelics
he had no file on any of this and I
don't think was going to get a file
Douglas Murray's Camp I think along with
yeah yeah well although I mean I think
Douglas is more
I mean Douglas and I haven't gone around
this track I don't think but
I feel in Douglas more of a um
kind of a yearning for this the
spiritual then then I ever detected in
the hitch you know the hitch was he just
prided himself on
um
being harder headed than that yeah it
was uh the grape and the Grain and uh
and the pleasure of good books
yeah I um I often think about
I have a couple of friends Alex is one
of them who's a huge fan of hitch and
and threw him even someone's passionate
about something you end up becoming
passionate about it because of that
passion yeah my housemate uh we always
watch videos of motocross rallycross
sorry where the guys are going down and
you'll see these dudes in anorax and
it's in the middle of Montana or or
Liverpool or some wooded area somewhere
and they've been there all night to get
the right spot and it's pissing down and
they're soaked wet through and they get
to see roughly 0.3 seconds right have a
car go past yeah and as they do it
they're so fired up and seeing someone
love anything
that much fires me up to watch it as
well there's there's this blog post by
Scott Alexander from Slate star coat now
astral codec 10 codex 10. and um no
sorry it wasn't it was uh eliada
yukowski and it's at the very start of
uh uh rationality from AI to zombies um
and he says the reason that rationalists
get the piss taken out of them so much
one of the many reasons that they get
the piss taken out of them so much is
it's rare to find anybody that loves
anything
now for anybody to have a degree of
passion and if you find someone who
stumbles upon the book of rationality
and thinks this gives me answers to a
lot of the cognitive bias problems that
I've been facing in my life
it's just easy to mock them it's easy to
mock passion in that regard in some
circles I think specifically being
British this is sort of genealogically
something that we've got right uh the
tall poppy piss taking mocking uh yeah
undertone and um
yeah from Alex loving hitch so much I
got into him too
and then you know thinking about what
sort of vacuum that perhaps could have
left and I don't disagree that
culture is bigger than any culture is
bigger than all of us but there are
certain voices you know Jordan as being
a good example at the right place in the
right time and so on and so forth that
can really be the you know the pebble in
the the stream that can direct things or
Trump on another side you know Elon kind
of now
um
yeah I often wonder about what what
hitch's Behavior would have been like in
the in the modern world yeah yeah well
I certainly miss him because
um
I mean there's so many moments where
they were just they were just perfectly
teed up for him in the last six years
and I mean just politically it just you
just would have
uh yeah there's no one I would like to
have pulled onto the field more than
than hitch at certain moments both both
left and right have you been uh keeping
abreast or have you noticed this trend
that's happened of westerners choosing
to convert to Islam in adult life
obviously you spend a lot of your career
criticizing Islam and now we have
I don't accuse of lopping these people
very well may truly believe in the
doctrine but in Andrew Taylor is is one
of them and downstream from that there's
on-street interviews with young British
youths with these um
Islamic Scholars or or imams or whatever
uh converting them on the street and
then like doing the doing the thing on
the on the street have you have you I
haven't I haven't seen those voxpop
conversions but
um I saw Andrew Tate's conversion
um
well I mean Islam is just mimetically
it's perfect for a specific audience you
know it's um
it's it's a it's a explicitly Macho
religion right it's a no
religion right it's just a
and this is it just you know it's a
like with Christianity
you have to pretend
yeah well you have to pretend to be
happy to be losing for the longest time
and you're basically just waiting for
Jesus to come back and rectify this
grave Injustice like you're the meek
shall inherit the earth you're just you
know there's no put in this place right
we're not going to win until we really
until we see you know Jesus arrive on
cloud trailing Clouds Of Glory
um so it's all going to be up for
the longest time and there's no
imperative that we really do anything
really like there's no expectation that
we're gonna win
before anything good happens I mean I
guess there's there's one Christian sect
where they do have an expectation of
of
of kind of winning you know a thousand a
thousand years of of millennial Glory
until and and then Jesus comes but for
most Christians it's just it's a story
of failure and then they get to say look
we were right you know Jesus you know
yeah yeah
with Islam there's an expectation that
they're going to conquer the world right
and there's an imperative to conquer the
world and for for serious Muslim just
like you don't have to be impatient
necessarily you can take as long as you
want but this is all we all know this is
moving in One Direction and you need to
be a spiritual Warrior and if you if you
take this really far if you become a
jihadist right you're and especially
doctrinaire militant you know True
Believer
well then you're a kind of spiritual
James Bond I mean it's like it's like
you get to be Jocko and care about and
know that you're going to go to paradise
right like so you get all the tools like
it's it's the it's this first person
shooter that literally get all the good
guns like it's not it's not this boring
I'm pretending to just I'll turn the
other cheek you know hit you know thank
thank you sir can I have another
um and you know where the it's it's
it's a high tea religion right and
that's why a schmuck like Andrew Tate
thinks it's he's had an you know a real
insight people can embracing it people
are seeing it as a redress to women of
the West who uh have been conned by
feminism into believing that these
things are good for them they're not
good for them we need you know no one's
happy look at the divorce rates look at
the 60 percent of U.S teenage girls aged
12 to 16 have regular or persistent
feelings of hopelessness yeah everyone's
only fans pathologically fapping
themselves into a early Monster Energy
whole or whatever it is that they're
doing right
the answer is a return to
something that's got a bit more Lindy
nature to it yeah well I mean that
that's the claim
that I want to deny I mean it's it's
explicitly retrograde I mean it is
regressive it is backward looking it is
not it is not using all of the good
ideas we've had in the meantime right
it's like it's a disavowl of the
presence and the near present I mean the
modernity in in the case of Islam it's a
it's a disavowell of nearly 1400 years
of
of wisdom and insight right it's it's a
it's a claim that in the 7th Century
somebody was so smart and so wise and so
prescient and so had so had his
together that everything we're thinking
about and talking about happened then
right so we should confine ourselves to
the products of that conversation
that's just I mean it's it's imbecilic
on its face right it's not to say again
it's not to say there's nothing useful
to come out of Islam but whatever is
useful we can use without believing that
Muhammad was visited by the Archangel
Gabriel and got and you know got the
last
You Know download from the creator of
the universe
um
it's just not this is not to deny any of
the cultural problems that someone like
Andrew Tate or
I mean there's lots of people we've
we've dragged into the conversation here
but like all of these people who I've
criticized to some degree
Tate or RFK or or um you could add Elon
to this all these people are
kind of living out the consequences of
their dissatisfaction with the presence
on the public stage and winning
a lot of
followers as a result they just like
they I you know they like the way these
guys are complaining about the obvious
excesses of the left for the most part
um
I have several problems with this one is
that most of these guys most of the time
some of them all of the time are
ignoring the obvious problems and and in
many cases quite a bit scarier problems
on the right right they really care that
the government tried to micromanage the
the
um
uh messaging about covid on Twitter
right that's the biggest story of the
decade right that's I've got I've got a
hundred podcasts in me and 100
newsletters in addition to that on that
topic but they don't really much care
about what happened on January 6th where
we had a sitting president who for
months had been
declining to support a peaceful transfer
of power and for the first time in our
history we did not have a peaceful
transfer of power and we had a sitting
president trying to visibly trying to
steal an election all the while claiming
an election had been stolen from him and
everyone around him knew that was
right
um
we were we were poised on the verge of a
constitutional crisis which may yet
return in 2024 and yet we have these
guys more worried about
you know trans overreach with respect to
bathrooms and
I get all that I get how infuriated and
so much of the the the the the woke
identitarian nonsense is but you have to
have some proportion and you have you
have to keep both
problems in View and why are people not
doing that in your view
well I mean so to some degree it's
people have you know a one-sided take
aligns with their biases in in many
cases they'll have political biases that
you know they were a creature of the
right they wanted to be a creature of
the right and this is very easy to focus
on what's wrong with the left and vice
versa you know if you're a creature to
the left it's easy to just be all Trump
all the time and you you don't have any
time for a criticism of wokeness right
you know you're going to run who I don't
know your
this could be wrong but you know you're
Trevor Noah on The Daily Show right like
yes tell me what John Don Jr did
wrong I've got time for it but hunter
Biden who cares right like so there's an
asymmetry there and
um
but
part of it I think is outside of normal
channels
there's there's audience capture right
like you find you get signal from the
noise on one thing you've just launched
your sub stack and you and you see that
people have endless time for your hot
take on covid and uh the dangers of mRNA
and the spike protein but doesn't that
sound scary it's called why they call it
a spike protein right so
let's do a hundred piece of content on
that topic right to the exclusion of
everything else that's happened I'm not
saying I know the MRNA vaccines aren't
going to some people up or haven't
already right it's a valid conversation
worth having but again there's there's
proportion here that gets totally lost
in each of these ecosystems and
what's happening out here in podcastan
and over there in sub-stakistan is
people find a
an appetite for a certain style of
conversation about a specific narrow
band of topics and they just go all in
on that for obvious reasons and I you
know
it's understandable
um
but I think it's um
it's shattering our society I mean we
have a society where increasingly and
this is again this is a near-term risk
of AI
you leave an existential risk aside we
have a society where
it's becoming increasingly difficult and
in many cases impossible to have a
conversation about facts that are
just
crucial to understand for the
maintenance of democracy for the for
public health for for you know on Myriad
fronts and we just we can't have a
real-time conversation that converges on
agreement it seems and it's just getting
harder and harder to do it what would be
the chance
in your mind
that we make it through the next
let's call it Century as a civilization
with something like us being functioning
still intact because
we have some breakdowns culturally many
breakdowns culturally we have bad
incentives we have a media system which
facilitates Bad actors either willfully
or negligently or ignorantly Rising risk
of artificial intelligence desktop
printers that can synthesize bio weapons
although there's some pretty good
uh closes in that that limit that from
happening uh population collapse
although not a true existential risk
something that's you know not it's
definitely not going to help uh nuclear
weapons still out there lurking around
all of the background natural risk that
just exists as a byproduct of us being
on a single planet at the moment yeah
how how Toby odds pills are you when it
comes to the conception of The Next
Century or two
well I mean like Toby I would just be
guessing
um
but I'm
I'm troubled that's like what I would
like to be able to say is
you know the chant the chance that
existential
uh
catastrophe is actually going to occur
is got to be minuscule right like it's
less than one percent like that's where
you'd want to be you'd want to you're
just guessing but very low probability
that we're going to wipe ourselves out
right then we're going to cancel the
future
um
I don't think that's the case like I I
just think it's it's whether it's I mean
even you know even a 10 probability
is awful
right I mean 10 comes up
you know you're just the expected value
of that just take out some dice and play
around and see what a 10 result looks
like how often that comes up right I
mean that's
that's terrifying and I yeah I think
there are many smart people who would
say
the risk of real catastrophe is is quite
a bit higher than 10 percent
um I think Tommy puts it at one in six
right over the next Century yeah I
believe so and and if you if you kind of
widen the footprint of you take
existential risk and you just
widen that to extreme risk right just
like okay it's not existential but you
know get you know you might want to
watch The Road Warrior films a few more
times because that's not nice that's
going to start to look like
the future right who wants to live in in
the aftermath of
societal collapse you know fundamental
societal collapse
um now it could be like that that's a
totally conceivable trajectory for our
species we could we could screw up
everything
and dig out and finally recover
uh and it could take a unnecessary we
could have this unnecessary and truly
heroin detour into
something awful for 100 years right but
who wants that and but if you but if you
add that to this
possibility space
yeah I don't you know how confident can
you be that something like that isn't
going to happen in the next hundred
years given what we're doing and what
we're finding it's so difficult to do
and that's what was so dispiriting for
me about covet and it's aftermath it's
not that I was
so worried about covid I was so worried
about our inability
to respond coherently
to something that was should have been
pretty simple to respond to right and
and so I I was for the longest time
there was this initial month where or
two where like who knows how bad this is
going to get who knows how bad this is
so yeah I was just thinking more about
covet but after
a couple of months I was much more
thinking about it as a a stress test for
society and for our information
ecosystem
um and for our cultural norms and our
politics and
I really do view it as a failed dress
rehearsal for something quite a bit
scarier let me lay this out for people
maybe who haven't heard you talk about
this before I haven't thought about
uh the the what happened with regards to
our cultural response uh for yeah you
might need a bit more grip on that there
you go
um
the way that you could see covert the
way that you could concept conceptualize
covet generally would be almost like a a
dress rehearsal almost like a
civilizational wide vaccine like a test
it was a a very weak virus in the end
thank God for that you know it didn't
the mortality rate wasn't there
transmissibility was pretty high but it
wasn't it wasn't super brutal when it
came to the deaths although not great
but what it did do
and I think you'll worry and mine align
here which is and I haven't heard
anybody no matter how ardently
anti-vax anti-lockdown anti-mask the
libtard are coming for us again
this is all Bill Gates's wet dream type
stuff it doesn't matter about those and
I have many agreements with those people
I haven't heard anybody
push back against what this did do was
Prime
the next four generations of humans for
as long as this is a still a cultural
meme that continues to take over
for the next time that something like
this potentially happens but this time
it's got a 30 mortality right or this
time it kills everybody under the age of
10 or this time it kills all women yeah
right what what what is the response
that occurs there given how we've been
primed previously and
I would love to hear you know the
I would love to hear the the like we
don't need to worry about that bro case
for that because regardless of how you
thought whether it was overreach whether
it was these these Cooks telling us to
stay in our houses you I'm getting
I'm going out and playing with the kids
and cutting open the locks to the local
park
that
it's made the situation worse it's made
the situation existentially
civilizationally it's primed us to be
more fragile
more
knee-jerk in terms of our response it's
it's not good
yeah well and that's where I parted
company with many of you know our fellow
podcasters and many of my friends and in
some cases former friends
in
the there's again this concern around
misinformation is the way I would tend
to frame it you know many people are
out in in podcast land are
allergic to a concern over
misinformation
uh because they're so concerned about
the the infringements or perceived
infringements of freedom of speech right
so the de-platforming of people from
YouTube like that is that is the
you know the Earth Crossing object that
we just we have we have to prioritize
with it like under no circumstances can
that happen like even with Alex Jones
like that's just we need to we need to
hold the line here we need to be free
speech absolutist of A Sort
um
and
that's more or less all they talk about
that within and then on the other side
we have people who are focused on the
misinformation problem they're focused
on the on the
I mean the real Calamity we just
witnessed where you just say like you
have public health information that just
cannot get through because there's so
much misinformation there's so many
conspiracy theories and there's so many
Pratt falls on the PO on the part of the
act the actual establishment that is
understandable that no one is is yeah
right
um
so
it's um
but they're they're still they're
they're taking the one that they
they can't afford to admit any of that
because they're so terrified around
about this erosion of trust in our
institutions right so it's like let me
take someone like
there's a few lenses we could look at
this Earth so you take like a character
like Anthony fauci right like I don't I
don't know if ouchy I don't know what's
true of him I don't know you know but
but I just know that
on on one side he is utterly maligned
right he's just this Goblin who is as
corrupt as
you could possibly imagine he lied about
everything he was wrong about everything
like he is just he is the antithesis of
an authority on covet or anything else
right on another side you guys just
bring you can still just bring him on
CNN as just the the most top shelf
Authority on public health we could ever
we could hope to have and The Only Thing
Worth thinking about is just how awful
his life has become as a result of how
he's been maligned over here right he's
just inundated with death threats he
needs a secret service detail uh because
all of these crazy people from Trump on
down have vilified him with lies right
now
I am totally prepared to imagine that
the truth is quite a bit more nuanced
that he could have been a great
scientist maybe he is a great scientist
maybe he did many great things but maybe
he's conflicted in all these other ways
which have been discovered by people
like RFK Jr or other people some people
might have been total crackpots but
they're right about this thing that
fauci did or didn't do right and that if
we're if we were going to parse it in
the middle here we would find oh yeah
you know what this Wuhan thing was
always gonna go Haywire he should have
known it he's he's culpable and was
lying about his culpability and that
exchange with him and Rand Paul was one
where Rand Paul whatever you think about
his politics was absolutely right and
fauci whatever you think about his
politics was basically just trying to
cover his ass with this you know
rabbinical definition of gain of
function which we all knew was
and we shouldn't be doing this research
and and it's it's uh
fauci for whatever reason can't admit
that he participated in something that
was awful right I don't know I don't
know if any of that's true I mean
whether fauci's involved with that but I
do have a lot of time for anyone who who
worries about gain a function research
and worries about what is happening in
Labs all over this world
um
but the problem is if you're focused on
what's what failed over here when you if
you're if you if you're focused on
this is a failed dress rehearsal what we
didn't manage during covid and the the
basic certainty that we're going to have
something much worse right uh and then
we have to prepare for that
it's very easy to see that
you just have to basically ignore all of
this like we just have to we just have
to stigmatize all of this as conspiracy
thinking all of these people are like
non-standard Bad actors none of them
have real jobs they're all they just
have podcasts and newsletters just get
the New York Times And The Washington
Post and Harvard University and all
these other institutions to hold the
line here
let's let's try to just not shine too
much light on the ways we embarrassed
ourselves we're certainly not going to
apologize for anything
um and let's hope we get a better
president Republican or Democrat next
time who's not a maniac who didn't do
give his first interview to Alex Jones
and let's just get back into a place
where everyone trusts the CDC again
right now
I don't agree with that but
like 75 percent of that could be right
right like I like I think we we could
age out of all of this Hysteria
you know just I mean just imagine what
would happen if
in 2024
we had a we had a reasonable choice for
the presidency right so Trump is not the
Republican candidate we have a more
normal Republican candidate who let's
say wins right
I don't know who that would be but let's
say whatever you know Nikki Haley wins
right we have President Haley she no
longer has to Pander to trumpastan to be
a republican we get a more normal
politics and we and many many smart
people however quietly begin to
internalize many of the lessons we
should have learned in the last few
years about
just how threadbare many of our
institutions have become and how woke
ideology
vitiated most of them right I mean how
political correctness and just sheer
lunacy contaminated are thinking about
so many things so much of the time in in
recent years
and we sort of age out of all of that
and we have
a more normal experience of the
grown-ups being in the room much of the
time being able to make real decisions
I think that's to be hoped for now I'm
not saying that we don't need Innovation
around that but like that some some
swing back into normalcy is to be hoped
for what's what
there's an alternate path to that future
that may be more realistic
um but the future worth wanting is a
future however we get there whether it's
just sort of like we just you know grit
our teeth and age into something more
normal or we innovate and dignify all of
this hysteria with with more and more of
a fair hearing but the thing we innovate
to is
real institutions that we can trust
right there is no future worth wanting
where we don't have institutions that
are trustworthy right so we need like it
cannot be up to
[Music]
a podcaster to tell you what's happening
really happening in Ukraine
when Putin says all right we're going to
use the tactical nukes now
uh
I mean first of all in a few months
you're not going to be able to know
whether he really said that or whether
that's a deep fake right so we're gonna
have we're going to need an institution
or at least a perfectly democratized
algorithm that is vetted by an
institution we trust that can say this
is how you tell whether that's really
Putin
or whether whether that's just some 18
year old who made that you know with
with a generative model
um and
but
regardless of how we how we
clean house with respect to basic
information we need institutions with
real experts who really capture our best
thinking and decision making on hard
problems you know so we and and we need
a population in every democracy that
most of the time can trust those
institutions like like when the state
department says listen this is what's
happening in Ukraine this is what
Putin's up to
you know uh this is why we have the
policy we have this is why we ship the
arms we shipped
we can't have a society where ninety
percent of the people are calling
ninety percent of the time
because no one trusts anyone in charge
that that's just that is the end of
democracy
but that's where we are that is that
that is where we I mean it much of the
time that's where we seem to be
certainly on if you use social media as
your reference point well you mentioned
this
I think in a different podcast about how
as soon as you exit social media you
realize
just how little of the world kind of
does take the cues about the world from
social media I think it's
maybe in the UK 10 or 20 between 10 and
20 of people have got a Twitter account
but then when you get on there I think
almost all of the content is created by
some ungodly small proportion of the
number of users so everybody else for
uh functionally is sort of wanking in
the corner and observing this this
thing go off and not contributing or
maybe signal boosting or or whatever but
it's it's the same culprits that are
talking about everything on all sides
yeah so you end up I remember this
during the general election in the UK to
them when whenever it was 2019 something
like that and if you looked at Twitter
you would have it would have been a
labor Landslide you know stormzy was
tweeting about it I'm pretty sure that
some of the actresses that play that
were in Game of Thrones they were
tweeting about how stormzy and
then Arya Starker tweeting about the
labor and how bad the conservatives are
and you know like never trustatory and
all this stuff and then we have the
biggest landslide in history I mean half
a century perhaps uh to go the other way
because where I'd been the cultural
thermometer that I'd put up the the
behind of of Twitter wasn't accurate
yeah except it was the opposite with
Trump and brexit right so like what I
was noticing with Trump
in in 2016 or I should have noticed is
that you know whenever I said anything
about Trump and or Clinton prior to the
election
the support for Trump I was seeing on
social media was like a hundred to one
over support for Clinton I mean it was
just crazy
and you know the polls were whatever you
know Trump had a you know 25 chance of
winning now again I was I never looked
at that poll and thought there's no way
Trump's going to win because at 25
chance is as we've just established
you know that comes up all the time
right so if you're going to take if
you're going to dignify Nate silver as a
as a real
um statistician with respect to those
those opinion polls yeah you can't be
consoled by 25 really when you're when
you're as worried as you had every right
to be about a trump presidency but
um
what I was seeing on social media should
have told me that the mainstream media's
conversation about this was not tracking
what was happening I mean well you can
see you know given this impending
ever increasing existential risk
background the landscape culturally that
people are inhabiting whether it be
mainstream whether it be alternative
Media or whatever I can understand why
people are feeling confused and
displaced and I've noticed on the
internet
a trend of cynicism I would give it a
single term it would be a very very high
amount of cynicism
given that there's so much despondency
in the world what what do you wish that
more lost or cynical or depressed people
knew what would you what would you what
would you tell them about this is my
world view everything's it's not
going to get better oh my God my family
my future there is no point even trying
in the people that say that things can
get better they're the ones that are the
real problem
what do you say to people that are
cynical
well many of the tools we've referenced
so far are incredibly useful and they
just take the stoic piece for instance I
mean the the real
comparison is
that's worth making is that
there's never been a moment in human
history where there has been more
opportunity for more people
to live a truly good life and not not
just to live a truly good life with
respect to your own selfish pleasure but
to affect the future in a propitious way
you just have massive leverage over the
future I mean we it's up to us to get
this right I mean this could have been
said you know I'm sure this could have
been said during World War II that and
it was it was true that yeah that the
difference between a Thousand-Year Reich
and and what we got was pretty big so
yeah
props to Churchill but the
we really are at a unique moment with
respect to the leverage uh and the and
the
the um
the disparity of outcomes suggested by
the power of our technology which is the
the exponential change we're seeing in
culture and and with respect to Tech
uh
this is new you know this A decade is
much longer now than it ever has been as
measured by the kinds of technological
and social change that we can see
and so if you can
if you want to have a meaningful life
if you want if you want Economic
Opportunity and you want you and you
want to exercise that opportunity in a
context where you can actually benefit
people at scale and the future at scale
it's never been easier to do that it's
never been it's like it just you know
the the iPhone that you have in your
pocket which is
you know in most people's case
fragmenting their life unnecessarily and
just becomes a source of of distraction
at best you know misery at worst
is actually an incredibly powerful
computer that would be you know two two
decades ago would have been an object of
of genuine magic right it's like it's
like it's just not the president of the
United States couldn't have had one 20
years ago right
um
and that's just going to keep happening
right it's just like we're all you know
again AI is is
is a is an ambiguous object at the
moment but
to have access to a large language model
is genuinely new and who knows what you
can do with it right it's like like it's
it's up to you to figure out how to use
these tools
um so the I there's massive opportunity
even if you're someone
who doesn't
feel like you have a ton of opportunity
by comparison with your you know friends
or with other people you've seen in your
Society
I mean I think if you have the bandwidth
to listen to a three-hour podcast you
almost certainly are someone who's in
something like a sweet spot right with
respect to opportunity it's just yeah on
the other side of that you I remember
you saying
um living and examining life is just one
insult after another you have to
maintain a sense of humor
yeah why what does that mean
well because what you the more you pay
attention
to your own mind you see that
it has absolutely no shame I mean it'll
think anything right like like the
person you meet it's not it's not easy
you don't meet Saint Francis of Assisi
you know in the mirror it's like you you
meet a
a Congress of selves right and many of
these selves are total right
they're just like you you meet
it's everything right and and you
ultimately can't take it personally
right like you're not you didn't create
yourself you didn't create your culture
you didn't create your Consciousness
like you're you are a
you find yourself here in this
circumstance and the question is what
can you do next what is available to to
experience next what is
possible given the kind of mind you have
and
um so we haven't you know we morally and
psychologically existentially we have a
navigation problem moment to moment and
there there are various tools you can
get in hand to be a a much wiser
uh and happier
pilot
that's one of the
reasons I think that Andrew human
particularly has been so
rapidly popular you know he was kind of
publicly didn't exist probably three
years ago maybe something like that and
now regularly is number one and number
two worldwide on every podcast chart
right that seems reliable and then
he's doing uh three and a half hour
treaties on caffeine yeah or something
and you know to get to that stage of
scientific communication I I wouldn't
have been able to predict I would I
don't think that I would have been able
to predict that people would have you
know we always talk about the podcast
Revolution people wouldn't have sat down
and listened to such and such and such
and such talk for Joker Wellington some
Medal of Honor recipient for six hours
and yeah blah blah blah heedman took
that to another level he took that to a
level where you think really great with
the the adenosine system for three and a
half hours
um and I think that one of the reasons
that Andrew particularly has been so
effective is that he is trying to cut
through all of the the chaos and he he
Bridges the gap between the the reliable
expert that's sufficiently credentialed
and and the uh upstart podcaster that's
got his hatredox bonafide's and he sort
of splits the two yeah yeah I mean he's
I love what he's doing I think he's
incredibly effective
but you'll notice he also bypasses all
of the contentious that that we
spent a lot of time talking about here
like he does not deal with politics he
does not want to offend anyone uh he
doesn't Gore anyone's sacred cow except
on these narrow topics of just how to
optimize your life with the best science
right now that is and there are other
you know friends who have podcasts more
or less in that vein
or Tim Ferriss I mean these are all
people who they have opinions presumably
about all this other stuff but
they don't tend to dig in on these any
of these culture wars through the
Minefield
you know you can figure out Trump on
your own time you can figure out black
lives matter on your own time tell you
about nicotine let's just let's just see
whether you should be you know getting
eight hours of sleep at night right and
whether you want to track that with the
the aura ring
um
I don't mean to trivialize any of that
that's all
super fun and useful
but there are other fires we have to
figure out how to put out and you can't
just ignore the fires right like like
it's just these these problems over here
are not going to go away even if we all
dial in our lives individually right and
it's it's
so yeah I mean I just think there's
I mean it's a kind of superpower to to
decide
whatever my opinion is on all of these
contentious topics
I don't feel any need to give it
I have all of these this is there's just
this absolute Feast of other things that
we can enjoy
and 95 of people are just going to love
the love what's on the menu I think he's
the only podcaster that I know of if you
actually go and have a look at his
reviews you know it doesn't take much
when you're working in point
points of stars out of 10 or out of five
or whatever it's just there's it's
maximum it's the maximum number of stars
that you can get it's either 10 on
Spotify or a five on on Apple podcasts
and you know one of the things that I do
appreciate maybe Andrew does have you
know strong views on
in K through 12 don't say gay bills or
whatever it is
um
but also one of the things that
I would and I think that you would agree
on as well that I'm definitely seeing
more and more is people who don't have
expertise in a particular area thinking
that this is wow I've got to follow you
know a million people follow me on
Twitter why why shouldn't I comment on
the Ukraine right it's like I don't I
don't go to Andrew huberman as brilliant
as he is yeah for his thoughts about the
Ukraine yeah and you don't fault him for
not broadcasting his thoughts to his
audience because why should he right
hey what's interesting about my life now
professionally is that I have these two
experiences running side by side like so
in my we've and we talk mostly about
kind of my podcast life I think but over
at waking up I have a completely
different experience of of what's coming
back at me from the audience like what
so
waking up is just pure
gratitude appreciation like nothing is
ever misconstrued there's a perfect
marriage between what I intend to say
and the way in which it gets received I
mean what not I mean not that I can
never nothing no one's ever confused but
it's like no one's ever accusing me of
you know really believing something and
say like it's just it's just pure
pleasure like it's just a it's just this
and it it was amazing to experience that
because
you know in my podcast life given that I
touch so many polarizing topics and
given that I offend people on both the
left and the right
I had completely lost sight of the fact
that it was possible to have a career
where
you put something out with good
intentions and people appreciate it and
that's the end of the story what's the
mechanism that's occurring there is it
the fact that everyone's there for
mindfulness is it the fact that it's
paywalled so you don't get the the sort
of Flotsam and Jetsam or whatever it is
that comes in and kind of spoils the
party for everybody have you reflected
on why it's so alive well it's also
because it's it's a
it's only a subset of of what I think
about and talk about right so it's like
I don't I don't take my critique of
trump into waking up uh Andrew yeah so I
have a version of of huberman's
experience on this kind of narrow band
of topics and the the topics are
increasingly wide it's not just
meditation I mean it really is kind of
practical philosophy it's like it's just
you bought the entire license the entire
Alan Watts Library Yeah Yeah from from
the what's foundation hours yeah
whatever yeah which it was just insane
and it was I think it got remastered I
really much very much enjoyed falling
asleep to that although that's not a
comment on how nice it is no no I do it
too he's great to sleep too
um
but
yeah so it's it's a it's a it's a
wonderful experience it hasn't convinced
me that I should shutter my podcast but
it it it's a it's a it's an amazing
corrective to what I experience as a
podcaster and as a writer of Books
because
um and as a public speaker I mean
whatever I've done professionally
for the last you know nearly 20 years
um
outside of waking up has been just this
reliably uh very strong but you know
bivalent response I mean I've got the
people who absolutely love what I just
said and the people who absolutely hate
it for precisely those reasons right
yeah and they'll flip-flop and cease a
week it's just you know and and then and
one of the ways in which I can notice
audience capture in other people
is when I go into their when I when I
occasionally so this may happen you know
I don't spend a lot of time doing this
now but
back in the day when I would look at
like the YouTube comments associated
with somebody else's podcast I mean just
to see how it kicked off
you know in certain people's feeds I
just noticed it's just a hundred percent
pain it's just like
is awful I mean the question is why
would I go on that like all these people
hate me right and
you reliably now they hate me because of
what I did or didn't say about coveted
vaccines or what I did or didn't say
about Trump or what I did it or didn't
say or seemed to say or they heard I
might have said about Hunter Biden's
laptop right so those people like their
kind of single issue people with respect
to those variables but like if I go into
um I mean it it may in fact be true of
your audience we'll see I mean it's like
it's like you we may find I would
imagine your audience is
somewhat evenly split but probably more
on the side of
everything I said about RFK and Trump
and covid and Jordan Peterson nah that's
not going to fly very well right like
that's like who the is this guy to
say any of that stuff that's going to be
the center of of kind of narrative
gravity I would I would guess
that's definitely true of Lex Friedman's
audience now right it's like and and
part of it is is that the podcast world
is
it almost has contrarianism built into
its DNA right so whenever you begin to
sound like an establishment shill right
everyone's spidey sense goes on no one
no one in the comments section gets 5
000 upvotes for saying well done for
towing the party line oh right I
actually agree with you on that
mainstream opinion so I I I don't
disagree about the way that the
podcasting Universe generally has that
and I I have been trying
aggressively for the last six months to
uh discipline my audience particularly
overtly a number of times
um we've been
aggressively you can there's a function
which you may have seen on YouTube which
is a hide user from channel uh which
causes this person to continue to be
able to type comments right but they're
just blasting them into the ether and no
one else gets to see them they can still
watch the things that you've got to
contribute to your play count and it's a
one strike and done policy now and I
don't mind about criticism I'm fine with
criticism I'm just not fine with people
that make me jerk unthoughtful responses
to something that that I don't want
those people here I think Tim Ferriss
has a similar policy he had it about his
Instagram he's like this is my house
take your shoes off right
um right so yeah I am
yeah I have the same I mean just to Echo
that but you know I have a lot of
experience with this because I used to
early in my podcast I would have wars on
my potty I'd bring someone on and it was
a real like knock down drag out debate
and then I would notice in the aftermath
my audience would just you know trash
that person on social media or wherever
and several times I you know explicitly
admonish my audience not to do that
because that's just that's just such an
ugly experience for the person to have
and however much I disagree with someone
on my podcast I never want them to feel
like they were just just mobbed by cycle
going on making sense it's synonymous
with having a a war and it does have it
and it still happens I mean I I think I
probably should ring that Bell again
because it just happened
um
I think I noticed it happen I mean again
I'm not on social media so I'm a bad
witness to this stuff but I looked
I think I looked I looked on Reddit
um
and I saw what happened in the afternoon
I had I had Mark Andreessen on recently
and we debated AI Rogan again
oh yeah okay I'm not sure I saw that but
um
so yeah he and he and I disagreed about
AI risk and you know but I you know it's
totally respectable uh respectful
conversation with him but it you know
had some with the character of a debate
and so you you you're very likely if
you're listening you're kind of it's a
bit of a horse race and you're either on
one side or the other and you know he
made a good point I made a bad point
kind of people are keeping score
um
and I did notice that just again this is
just Reddit and I spend 15 minutes on it
uh you know once every two months but I
noticed that my audience was just
on him in a way that it's just
not good for me if like if you were if
they're my audience if they if they want
to support me it is not supportive of my
Enterprise to on my guests in that
way right and so it is with you or any
other podcasters how do you how do you
um get around that because there's
definitely a part of me
whether I'd be a user of social media or
a Creator on social media much more
creative than a user
um
I I do despair seeing thankfully not my
own comment section much but a lot of
comment sections show me as far as I can
see the absolute worst of humanity and
and it seems to me that the
the best thing that you could try and
cultivate as a creator of any kind is a
reasonable audience I think that that
the goal of a reasonable only what's the
best faith interpretation of what this
person's saying I listen to this guest
or I read that sub stack or I subscribe
to their YouTube channel or whatever
presumably because I think that they are
a good curator that they have a good ear
that they are acting in good faith that
they're doing all of these things and
you descend into the comments of even
somebody that seems pretty un
objectionable and it's a cesspit
sometimes yeah yeah now that was one of
the things that I I mean that's why I
don't spend any time on any social media
really I mean I think there's something
baked into the
to The Forum uh which I mean you know
I'm agnostic as to whether or not you
could actually build a social media
platform that would encourage all good
stuff and discourage all bad stuff but
um
and we might the truth is we might
actually launch a community forum for
waking up
and
Telegraph the fact that this is an
experiment you know this we could be
yanked this at any time but let's just
see how this goes because in that
Community with that the list of topics I
think it could actually be possible to
have you know almost entirely good
supportive conversations the wildest
thing is that we're in a a time where
people want connections more than ever
atomized Society individualistic
collapse of grand narratives uncertain
about the world fear and strife and
concern
yeah if we want that and yet the
behavior of some very loud very
offensive people on some platforms
colors the experience of of everybody's
right you know there is such a Matthew
principle around yeah the exposure of
particular posts everywhere right it's a
small number of posts to get all of the
the the reach from a small number of
people who are the only ones that post
from a small number of people who are
the only ones that have an account and
there's also an algorithmic choice that
is dictating that which is you know it
is
out the gamification is based on outrage
and strangely misinformation I mean it's
like misinformation is spreading better
than real information I made a patient
debunking of an untruth is boring and
the lurid untruth is is captivating and
it and it spreads that's the the
asymmetry principle right it
takes a lot less energy to produce
than to refute it therefore the
world is filled with unrefuted
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah so I mean I think it might be
possible to do but I think it would be
in a it wouldn't be at scale it wouldn't
be at Twitter scale or or Facebook scale
um
and I think you would have you'd have to
have I mean
you would have to have a low tolerance
for heavy moderation right and
and so this is why you know this is why
I don't understand the Twitter is a
Public Square argument right that and
that we should all be free speech
absolutists with respect to social media
none of these social media all these
social media platforms are businesses
some are even private businesses
um
my concern about Free Speech runs to the
owners and operators of those businesses
and not not wanting the gov not wanting
anyone to be able to force them to be
associated with speech that they find
awful right so like if if I create a
social media platform over at waking up
and notice that it's slowly getting
populated by Nazis
I should be able to have a no Nazis
policy on my own platform that I built
with my investment right it doesn't
matter how big it gets if there's good
it's gonna you know if it has 20 million
people on it
I should be able to kick the Nazis off
right and like so so my concern about
free speech is for the person is
essentially for the publisher
who doesn't want to publish Nazis
um
and the truth is it's you know if
the the
also if you call the call the bluff of
the Free Speech absolutist you recognize
that there's no there there it's just
impossible to be a free speech
absolutist because not even 4chan is a
circumstance of free speech absolutism
right I mean free speech absolutism is
everything right every awful thing all
the time and you just can't nobody wants
to be there and no it's just it's just
too much noise to that signal and so you
you have the moment you admit that you
have to curate sometimes you're going to
be making judgment calls and so then and
then you just have to have whatever
principles you have by which you do that
and if your principal is no Nazis well
then that's your principle and people
understand that and then someone can
start a a Nazi forum
you know Stormfront or some other spot
great I think that should be legal right
you should be able to have a Nazi social
media platform
um yeah I just don't have to be there or
support it
so what are you doing next what's next
on the work bucket list you know it's
it's really just
you know almost entirely continuing in
these two channels of of waking up the
app and making sense the podcast and I
have
stuff I want to write but it's very hard
to incentivize myself to write it
because it's harder it takes longer I
reach fewer people and it it pays less I
mean like all the incentives are aligned
against me writing another book so
um
I haven't and you know as if by Magic
I've I notice I haven't done that uh but
I think I ultimately I will because it's
only when I'm writing that I am taking
the time to think through each topic as
fully as I I'm capable so I think I I
mean there's some writing built into my
podcasting and and my work on waking up
too because some of what I record is
essentially an audio essay or
you know there's some prep in involved
in some things but how arduous is that
you know you've got a daily meditation I
I think I've I don't know the daily
meditation the daily is not
lie of that day I mean I record them and
so we have a you know we have a
reservoir of daily message still 365
times pretty much 10 minutes or 15 or 20
I know that you can kind of stretch it
in between some clever algorithmic stuff
but that's no you know I often speak to
authors that talk about the difficulty
of the the audiobook portion of of
reading the how many times do you put
your foot in your mouth and go right I
guess we gotta I'm gonna have to redo
that particular part of explaining about
why that tree is something worth looking
at or Whatever It Is Well waking up is
in the process of really outgrowing me
because there's so many other people
contributing to it right so there's lots
of other teachers and Scholars and
scientists and
um
so you know one part of it I essentially
have a podcast where I just talk to
people and sometimes those conversations
show up on both the podcasts and the app
but often not
um
but then I would just have a lot of
other people producing content so I have
many more things I feel like recording
for waking up but there
there's no rush Like the Wolf is really
not at the door with waking up well it's
my podcast there's this expectation that
you know next week there's going to be
another podcast unlike you where it's
that every two days or whatever you know
so three times a week you know I do not
have that Cadence but
so it's um but happily it's you know my
podcast is structured around
what I what what I want to think about
and read and talk about next right so I
mean so it's often a matter of
what book do I feel like reading next
and now I realize I can talk to the
author you know so and so it's such a
it's like a
you know
I mean I'm among the luckiest people on
Earth to be able to make a career out of
doing what I would do for free anyway
I've said this all along I always used
to regret the fact that at University I
didn't take psychology or philosophy I
took business management which taught me
nothing about business and then did a
masters in international marketing and
that also told me nothing about
marketing and I was always
um
regretful I I was wistful for a academic
career that I never had because as soon
as I pulled my head out of my ass toward
the back end of my 20s I realized that I
had all of this stuff that I was
choosing to be interested in so I could
have chosen to be passionate about the
degree instead of the one that had to
force myself to be competent in yeah and
it would have all been fine but then you
know by whatever Quirk of the simulation
that we're in that means that I can talk
to people that I would talk to for free
and call it a job I've been able to
structure the exact University syllabus
talking only about the exact niche of
the best particular Creator or academic
or intellect or writer on that one topic
only for as long as I want yeah and then
no one assesses me afterward and if I
mess up it doesn't matter and if I want
to Kareem the interview off and talk
about hamburgers for 10 minutes then so
be it and I can do exactly what I want
it's
you know the for all of the the internet
is difficult and and negative comment
sections cause me to feel a little bit
sort of uh it tarnishes the experience
broadly it's a complete dream that I
kind of can't really believe is
is happening and you know yeah you've
been a great big influence thank you
you've been a really big influence on uh
the movement that I went from
whatever I was before to the adult
infant that I think that I am now and I
appreciate the stuff that you do I
appreciate your time today where should
people go where should they keep up to
date given that you are absent from
everything in a digital ghost now where
should they go
um just uh waking up.com is for waking
up and samharris.org is everything else
associated with me that is not a deep
fake that will soon be coming no doubt
Sam I appreciate you thank you yeah
great to meet you